Well, we want to welcome you back to the
SA Sabbath series. We're looking tonight
at a response to Miles Kettlesen, and
this is part one. I've titled it God's
week. So, we're going to look at Miles
Kettlesson tonight. This is a doctrinal
theological investigative study of
biblical issues, and this particular
series is about the Sabbath. So, we're
going to respond to Miles Kettlesen
tonight.
And of course, the title of our series
is also facing the critics of those who
are attacking the 7th Day Adventist
Church. We're going to look at carefully
tonight. Miles has done several videos
and I mean a lot of videos actually and
podcast he does that and uh quite quite
many of them he's done. And so we're
going to look at them tonight. He's done
stuff on Doug Bachelor and Mark Finley
and Ted Wilson and so many people out
there. He's done all these videos on uh
attacking and podcast attacking Seventh
Day Adventist. So, we're going to look
at it. What we're going to do is we're
going to answer it's answering the
critics from the Bible one point at a
time. You see, when people get into to
debates on YouTube and they get into
these debates, they go off into all
kinds of things. And so, I prefer just
dealing with the issue right here like
we're doing. And so, we're going to look
at answering the critics from the Bible
one point at a time. So, we'll look at
it tonight. Like I said, he attacks Doug
Bachelor and the things that Doug says
and and also Mark Finley. He attacks all
of them. And so we're going to look
tonight carefully at some of the things
that Miles actually says.
Well, hey there.
Thank you for being here, especially if
this is your first time with us,
Adventist or otherwise. We're going to
be talking about one of my favorite
topics tonight, especially in the
context of Adventism, and that is the
Sabbath. So, question of the night.
Did SDA pastor Jeff Dowel refute
answering Adventism's position on the
Sabbath?
Or better yet, does he even understand
the position?
Did SDA pastor Jeff Dael refute
answering Adventism's position on the
Sabbath?
This is going to be what we look for
tonight and what will be under
examination. Along the way, I will have
to break down a number of things. But in
that intro clip, we heard the infamous
I'm attacking the Seventh Day Adventist
Church,
which is the SDA victim complex, rearing
its uh head again. Jeff, I didn't attack
any of the men that you mentioned. I
critiqued their theology.
There have been a handful of times that
I have outright stated that these
individuals were lying, in which case I
stand by those claims. But that also
isn't attacking, sir. The word attack,
folks, involves uh violence and
aggression. It evokes a certain type of
picture for people. This is a sort of,
you know, poisoning of the well, if you
will, before his hearer gets into, well,
you're not even going to hear anything
from Jeff that I actually say. You're
going to get Jeff's convoluted
understanding of what I said, um,
regurgitated to people. Um, and so he
poisons the well there at the beginning.
You know, he's one of these critics that
attacks the Adventist church, even
though he's going to do the exact same
thing that I did in those videos,
critique theology.
But I've stated, Jeff, about all the
gentlemen that you mentioned, I think
they truly believe what they're saying.
I don't know them from Adam. I believe
they're sincere and genuine people, but
they're deceived just like you and your
organization think I am.
Which is why this silly charge of being
attacked is always so interesting
because what we're about to listen to is
this man, like I said, do the exact
thing in his presentation that I did in
mine, critiquing theology and discussing
biblical issues.
So, why is he holding inconsistent
scales? Why the double standard? I don't
whine and cry that I'm being attacked
despite the countless people out there
that disagree with my theology and
countless Adventists. Like every week
I'm getting inundated, folks. That's the
only reason I know about videos like
this. We just get inundated with all
these people that make videos about this
platform. I don't sit here and whine,
look, they're attacking me. Oh
yeah, it's time for Adventists that say
this to grow up, including Mr. Dowel. If
you can tell, it's going to be a uh
feisty night.
This charge is childish and it shows one
of the the weaker points of SDA
pathology. You're not being attacked by
having your theology critically
examined. Give me a break. Especially
considering Jeff, you're a part of a
movement, sir, that claims to possess
the theological God particle, the theory
of everything, the antidote to
theological division which is strictly
supposed to be relegated for us
Babylonian Protestants.
But furthermore, this man is a salesman,
folks, for an organization that's built
upon attacking Christians. That is if
critiquing theology is considered
attacking.
Their entire MMO is to criticize
Protestant and Roman Catholic theology.
an organization that upholds a woman who
they claim was divinely inspired and
wrote things like
that as someone who has rejected their
message, my prayers are an abomination
to God, that I'm a tool of Satan, that
the time of my salvation is up and
there's no hope for me because I once
affirmed the SDA message and I no longer
do.
SDA pastor Kevin Morgan was just on here
a few weeks ago with Steve Daly. We
brought this up and he admitted to it.
He said, "Yep, that's that's what the
the the vision was saying."
Things like that. As a former Adventist,
people like myself will be leading the
charge to hunt down 7th Day Adventists
globally to have them murdered.
That Christians are worse than heathens.
But Adventists aren't to tell them that,
lest it close up opportunities for them
to evangelize us, amongst a mountain of
other slanderous claims. So, let's lay
off the attacking rhetoric and not throw
stones from a glass house. But before we
get too far into it, I have to lay some
groundwork. Since we're not going to
hear, like I said, Jeff actually play
anything that I said. Instead, we're
going to hear his warped quote mining of
my presentation. We're going to start by
playing the introduction from my
presentation that Jeff is critiquing and
responded to. Pay very close attention
here, folks. Tonight we're going to be
looking at a presentation that celebrity
SDA pastor Doug Bachelor did uh a couple
of years ago or I guess a few years ago
at this point uh titled is Sunday sacred
wherein he misrepresents the Christian
church but more specifically
first day sabotarians
I'm going to try and do my best tonight
to be clear and thorough as I am fully
aware of the sway of this doctrine in
particular within Adventist ism as well
as the sour taste that it has left in
many former Adventists mouths. However,
it is important and it's important that
we go where the truth leads and so that
is where I'm going to be coming from
tonight. To do that, it is going to take
time. I think you guys are starting to
notice a uh pattern here when it comes
to live streams. This will be a
two-parter. Part two will happen next
week because uh this is not a soundbite
two-s sentence topic despite the SDA
church thinking such. This is a whole
Bible topic that needs to be looked at
much more deeply than just throwing out
proof texts. Whether you're on the for
side, the against side, whatever side.
Um it it requires a lot more than that.
So, first I want to say I know there
will be lots of people that disagree
with me on this, not just Adventists.
The ears of a lot of former Adventists
are going to be a little twisted and I
get that, but track with me, please.
All right. So, I made it clear from the
very beginning that it was to show two
primary things.
One, how Doug Bachelor and the standard
SDA claims misrepresent
the Sabbath position held by people like
myself.
Doug's claims not being unique to him.
They're standard SDA arguments and I
stated that in the presentation as well.
It's nothing about Doug personally. He
just happens to be uh understanding of a
TV slot, for example. He knows how to
get through his information quickly,
which makes him a good case sample to
use because he represents the system
typically, the standard fair stuff. So,
we just used him as an example. But that
was one. And two, it was to simply
educate people on the position and help
them better understand the differences
between what people like myself are
saying about the Sabbath versus the
Adventist position. Okay? And I also
very clearly stated that this is not a
sound bites and proof text level topic,
but it is a whole Bible topic. Meaning
it spans from Genesis to Revelation.
It's a thematic doctrine that has a
thread all throughout uh scripture and
it requires an analysis from that
vantage point. In other words, I was
giving a redemptive historical
presentation on the subject.
The same thesis was true of the
presentation he referenced with Mark
Finley. It was even in the thumbnail.
Mr. Finley butchered the reason for
Christian worship on the first day and I
demonstrated as much. It's irrelevant if
Adventists disagree. You should still be
able to represent what people are saying
by giving a steelman of the position
even if you disagree. So, Mr. Dowel,
that's what we're going to look at or
look for from you. You claimed at the
beginning of your presentation, like we
heard in the beginning, that this was a
doctrinal, theological, investigative
study of biblical issues where you're
going to carefully look at some of what
I said. Okay? I will be repeating myself
a lot tonight to drive home the points.
Repetition is how people learn. He also
happens to just keep repeating himself.
So, I'm going to keep repeating myself
as well. And whether you agree with me
or disagree with me, whether you're an
Adventist, former Adventist, Christian,
whatever it may be, hopefully you will
have a better understanding either way.
Okay. As a heads up, we're going to
listen to Jeff at one and a half speed
because we have a lot to get to and not
a lifetime to do it. This will only be
part one out of a multi-part series.
Here we go.
House believes that Adventists are not
Christian. I'm going let you know that
right now. He believes that Adventists
are not Christian and that his mission
is to expose the false teachings of
Adventists and get out of Adventism.
That's his whole purpose of his videos
and podcasts is to attack Adventist,
name calling, all these things. Get out
of Adventist. It's a cult and all this
and that. Miles claims to have and
here's what he says. I'm quoting him. He
says he claims to say that the strongest
apologetic against the SDA church's
theology of the Sabbath. He claims to
have that apologetic, meaning he's got
the strongest case against Adventists on
the subject of the Sabbath.
All right. So, already burning straw man
right out of the gate. But Jeff, yes,
this platform does not consider Seventh
Day Adventism to be Christian. Notice I
said Seventh Day Adventism.
The SDA church preaches a false gospel
and a false god called the heavenly
trio. And you guys are stuck with that
title because your false prophetist uh
that you guys uphold gave you that and
you guys bind people's consciences to
that. However, Jeff, I have not said and
do not claim,
nor have I ever, that all Seventh Day
Adventists are not Christian.
And the proof of this is on our website,
which I'm grateful that the record for
exists.
Notice from a short article on our
website titled, "Our Seventh Day
Adventists saved?" One of the featured
articles on the homepage of our website.
Folks,
it's never wise to make blanket
generalizations, especially when it
comes to salvation. We are not elect
detectors, nor does God call us to be.
Many Seventh Day Adventists are true
Christians,
but this is in spite of official Seventh
Day Adventist teaching, not because of
it.
There are many souls caught up in
Seventh Day Adventism that do not
believe the damnable heresies the
organization teaches.
Nevertheless, it is important to know
that the organization
teaches a false gospel, Galatians 1 6-9,
and proalitizes a false god. 2
Corinthians 11:1-4. Neither of which can
save anyone because they aren't real.
This puts the organization
outside the bounds of Christian
orthodoxy. Because of this, born again
Christians should not be associated with
a false church. Christians should always
be ready to share the true gospel in
Christ with Seventh Day Adventists like
we should with all tribes, tongues,
peoples, and nations.
And numerous uh you know former
Adventists out there can tell you I've
told them this exact thing.
So Jeff, you have once again
misrepresented answering Adventism
because Seventh Day Adventism the
organization is not Seventh Day
Adventists
the individuals.
This is my first rodeo with Adventists
folks.
Yeah, I know there's a spectrum. I know
not all Adventists I've been stating
this for years well before this platform
existed. I distinguish all groups across
the board this way. You shouldn't just
say for example all Roman Catholics are
lost. No, they're not.
You don't know all people.
There's a differentiation between an
organizational body and the actual
individual people. People need to be
looked at on an individual basis, not
damned based on their association that
they may have to a particular group.
And many seventh adventists do believe
in the true Christ and do believe in the
true gospel, despite those beliefs
clashing with the organization's
officially stated positions.
But Jeff, my claim that Seventh Day
Adventism isn't Christian shouldn't be
shocking because you're a salesman for
an organization that says the same thing
about me. I'm an apostate, part of
Babylon, and I share the same fate as
Satan. We've looked at this numerous
times on this platform. Both the SDA
church's website and Ellen White are in
perfect harmony on this. So again, I
ask, why the double standards, sir?
I actually have the wherewithal and the
coahjones to state what I believe openly
because I care enough about Adventists
to shoot it to them straight and not
keep quiet letting them walt on into the
fire saying kumbaya, you know,
everything's just hunky dory,
everything's great, haha type stuff.
Adventists can hate my guts, hate my
approach, repudiate me, and many of them
do. But I love SDAs enough to say the
hard part out loud and be honest about
it. And you all need tough love, sir.
You need tough love, not kumbaya around
the fire.
And I'm willing to have a target on my
back for the sake of being the alarm
clock that God hopefully uses to wake up
as many Adventists as possible because I
want them to be saved and come to know
the beauty of the gospel. Purpose of
this platform is not to name call.
But as a salesman for the SDA
organization, Jeff, you're fully aware
of these claims about me being an
apostate from the SDA church and would
have to at least outwardly profess to
uphold those yourself, which would
include that those of us that reject
your guys' special message will share in
the same fate as Satan. Yes, that's what
this church teaches.
the sheer irony of him trying to talk
about the the mission of answering
Adventism from the page regarding the
remnant and its mission on the SDA
church's own website. We have looked at
this before and there's numerous others.
Notice what part of their mission is.
Quote, "The Apostle John, the last of
Jesus's disciples and the one who wrote
Revelation, tells us exactly who Satan
will target. Satan's goal is to harm
those who keep God's commandments and
believe what Jesus taught. But among the
lawless uh among the lawlessness of the
corrupted world, God will call for his
devoted followers to separate themselves
from those who have rejected him. Then I
heard another voice from heaven saying,
"Come out of Babylon, my people, lest
you take part in her sins, lest you
share in her plagues, for her sins are
heaped high as heaven, and God has
remembered her iniquities." Revelation
18:4-5.
Those who do not come out of the
wickedness of the world will be subject
to the same fate as Satan, utter
destruction.
God refuses to let sin go on forever.
And those who hold on to sin will have
to account for their deeds. 2
Corinthians 5:10. But God's remnant,
God's remnant people are not just
supposed to hide in holes as they
separate themselves from the world. God
has a job for his people to do. A
message they, the remnant, will deliver.
For many people, this message will make
the difference between eternal life with
God and the permanent second death. All
who hear it will have to make a single
vital decision, either to follow God or
side with Satan and share his fate.
Close quote.
So all former Adventists are a part of
the lawless world supposedly and we
share in the same fate as Satan because
after hearing the SDA church's message,
if you disagree with it, regardless of
how valid your reasons might be, you've
supposedly rejected God.
Rejecting the SDA church's errant
theology is akin to holding on to your
sin.
And this also has Ellen White's
prophetic stamp of approval as I have
shown numerous times before.
So just so we're clear, let's not try
and play this game that I'm some
attacker of Adventism that doesn't think
Adventists are Christian when your
organization holds the same view just in
reverse. Except they add to it that you
have to become Adventist to be saved and
ready for the second coming. Whereas I
don't think you have to be a
Presbyterian to be saved. You have to be
in union with Christ.
with regards to the mission of answering
Adventism. He brought that up.
Jeff, your description was ironic
considering what we just saw from your
organization's mission, especially
considering that I cited an actual
statement from your organization on your
guys' mission, and you didn't even
bother to actually site ours. And since
you didn't, let's refresh everybody's
mind for those that don't know,
including you, Jeff.
This is our public mission statement,
and it has been from day one.
Started by a third generation former 7th
Adventist, we have grown into a vibrant
gospeloriented apologetics organization
that is clarifying the divide between
Adventism and historic biblical
Christianity. Our mission is to
demystify Adventism, unpacking its
doctrines, unraveling its history, and
underscoring its leadership through the
prism of biblical Christianity. We equip
we equip Christians with knowledge and
reach Adventists with the true Christ
and his gospel elevating his sovereign
grace and freedom to save for his own
eternal glory. Solely deo Gloria
very simple and very clear. So Mr. Dowel
so far you are not off to a good start
sir when it comes to accurately
representing me. You are engaging in the
logical fallacy called poisoning the
well by doing this. Giving your
listeners an inaccurate representation
to set the stage in their mind that I'm
some angry bitter critic of Adventism,
which has been the standard MMO, folks
for a long time, since the movement's
inception.
Jeff, you're not the first Adventist to
do this, and you most certainly will not
be the last. My mission is not what you
claimed. It's not to name call. It isn't
to expose Adventism. We're not a
discernment ministry or some watchdog
blog or whatever. I've explained this
many times before.
This platform is an inward-f facing
effort. It's to raise the general
consciousness of the body of Christ to
understand the doctrine of this
movement, namely, and more specifically
the great controversy worldview and how
it distorts standard Christian
vocabulary, but means something entirely
different which deceives people.
This then better protects the body from
your guys' proitizing efforts, which are
primarily targeted at Christians.
It also equips the body to better be
equipped to reach Seventh Day Adventists
with the truth, which reinforces that I
want Adventists to be saved.
No differently than you guys claim to
have a special only for you guys present
truth end times message that you think
people need to hear to be ready for the
second coming. So shame on you for your
caricatured representation of me and
your consistent use of unequal weights
and measures which God in the proverbs
says he hates. Then he mentioned my
claim regarding my apologetic for the
Sabbath being the strongest. This is
exactly correct and I continue to stand
by my claim, Jeff, not because it has
anything to do with me, but because I've
studied this topic with a specific
detail and I'm convinced it's the most
faithful position to the biblical text.
And as I said earlier, I believe the
truth is the anvil that can wear out any
hammer. I'm not going to cry and claim
you attacked me for disagreeing and
criticizing it. I welcome such.
But Jeff, this claim by me is peanuts
compared to what your organizational
leadership claims and publishes in the
official publishing arms of the SDA
church. We've looked at Herb Douglas on
this in the December 2000 issue of
Ministry Magazine probably 15 times at
this point. It's linked on our website
in multiple articles. He was very
forthright and clear-cut as it comes.
Your organization allegedly possesses
the equivalent of what Stephven Hawking
called the God particle. Only Douglas
calls it the theological God particle,
the theory of everything, the mind of
God. You guys uniquely possess this. And
it's allegedly what keeps the SDA
movement from being doctrinally confused
like all those Babylonian Protestants.
Which would mean your organization is
effectively telling us the exact same
thing I said about my apologetic for the
Sabbath. Except they're saying it about
all of your doctrines. They're
impenetrable. Allegedly.
I've never even come close to making a
statement at that level. I could be
wrong on my view about the Sabbath. I
don't think I am obviously or I wouldn't
believe what I do. But this shouldn't be
shocking when one understands the claims
your organization has made in comparison
to mine. And for the record, this
apologetic isn't unique to me. I didn't
originate it. And I say this all the
time. I stand on the shoulders of
giants. I am trying to synthesize and
share information here. Not originated
as some leader or some, you know, just
me in my Bible and come follow answering
it. That's not what's going on here at
all. I try and synthesize things into
digestible bits because we are an
education platform.
Miles believes and teaches a Sunday
Sabbath in creation. This is what he
teaches. And for the next several
meetings, I'll be going through each of
the points that he raises in his defense
against Adventists as an apologetic
being claiming to be the strongest
apologetic against Adventists on the
Sabbath. Now, here's what he says. The
SDA church has no clue what they
criticize.
No clue. So he's saying you Adventists
have no clue about what you criticize.
And here's his claim. I mentioned it
already, but here's his claim. He claims
to believe that he has the strongest
apologetic against the SDA church's
theology of the Sabbath. Well, I'll tell
you friends, as you go through the next
few meetings, if he has the strongest, I
would really hate to see what weak
apologetics is against Seventh Day
Adventist. if he's got the strongest.
All right. So, Jeff, there are only
three options here. Okay. You either
didn't actually listen to what I said,
you did, but you didn't understand what
I presented, or you're being dishonest
because you misrepresented my position.
Again, folks, we're a minute in.
A minute.
It's like a machine gun of error. I do
not teach a Sunday Sabbath creation.
I'll save showing how this is a
misrepresentation for when he launches
into why he's saying this, but it needs
to be stated upfront. Jeff, you are
incorrect, sir, and your entire critique
is predicated upon these starting point
errors.
This was also the title he put up on his
introduction slide to make it appear
like the name of my presentation
is what he is calling it like he's
critiquing what I named it. Notice
down at the bottom Sunday the Sabbath in
creation.
Again I will explain his confusion on
this in a little bit. But then he
mentions me saying the SDA church does
not understand what they criticize. This
is exactly correct, Jeff. Which is why,
like I showed earlier, part of the
thesis of the presentation he is
critiquing was to demonstrate all of the
SDA church's favorite straw men
regarding new creation sabotarians like
myself.
And I could have picked countless SDA
figures to use as an example of the
standard fair SDA arguments. Like I
said, Doug simply got through them
quickly, allowing for us to respond in a
timely fashion.
And I will look forward to seeing with
the audience tonight if this still holds
true regarding Mr. Dowel and if he's
able to steal man the position that I
put forth before his attempted
reputation.
It does need to be reiterated though
when I say the SDA church adventist etc.
in this context I'm referring to 7th day
Adventism trademark the organization
not random individuals as though there
isn't a single Adventist on the planet
that hasn't encountered these art.
Obviously not, Jeff. I'm speaking
organizationally here, and I've made
this clear in numerous videos. It's in
the mission statement. I distinguish
between individual Adventists
and 7th Day Adventism, the organization.
I've been very vocal about this, but
remember what he said there, that if my
apologetic is the strongest against the
SDA position, then he would hate to see
what weak is.
Remember
that as Mr. Dowel, a salesman of the
great controversy worldview who
allegedly has direct access to the mind
of God, seeks to engage my arguments,
there's going to be a lot of stopping
and starting tonight, folks. Even with
the audio sped up, we have a lot to
address
going to see. So, here's what I'm going
to say. I'm going to have a challenge
for the viewers and those who are
watching tonight's meeting. A challenge
to the critics and viewers of this video
that I'm doing tonight. And here it is.
Take a piece of paper and write down
your answers to every question asked in
this video and then go back over your
answers and see if you contradict
yourself. That's a very crucial point.
So that's the challenge I have to those
critics out there and viewers who may be
watching this. Now I want to say it
again. Take a piece of paper and write
down your answers to every question
asked in this video and then go back
over your answers and see if you
contradict yourself.
Okay. So this is the crucial point he
says. Write down all the questions he
asks. Answer them and see if you
contradict yourself, which assumes the
questions he asks are valid and are
built on solid foundations.
Remember a couple weeks ago when we
listened to SDA critic of Christianity,
Ivor Meyers? He did the same sort of
thing, but his questions and claims
ended up being dead on arrival because
they were predicated on faulty premises.
So let's see how Jeff's questions pan
out.
Now, I want to start off tonight with a
a PhD, a Dr. Philip Kaser. And Miles has
gotten some of his teachings from Dr.
Philip Quaser. And we're going to see
some of the things that Dr. Quaser says.
And it's interesting because Miles um
has followed some of the very teachings
that Dr. Quaser has. Now, Philip Quaser
has degrees in education. Did you notice
what I said? Degrees. Degrees in
education, theology, and philosophy. He
was ordained in 1987. He currently
serves as senior pastor of Dominion
Covenant Church, a Presbyterian CPC
church in Omaha, Nebraska. Now, Dr.
Kaser makes his arguments based on his
distinction between the first day of the
week, Sunday Sabbath, and the seventh
day of the week, Saturday Sabbath. He
makes a distinction between those two,
and he refers to the first day, Sunday,
as Sabbath. and he makes a distinction
between the first day Sunday Sabbath and
the seventh day of the week Saturday
Sabbath. Now Dr. Caseer mentions Dr.
John's Parker. Now it's interesting
where some of these guys get their
ideas. Now I mentioned this and I'll
tell you why. Because remember um Miles
claims he has the strongest apologetics
against the Seventh Adventist Church on
the Sabbath. And he looks at this and
says Adventists have no clue of what
they're arguing against. No clue. But I
want to share something with the viewers
as we go through this tonight. This
teaching is actually nothing new. What
they've done is they've modified maybe
but it's really to the core our
substance. It's nothing new at all.
Matter of fact, some of the things that
Kaser has drawn from is a book called
The Sabbath Transferred. Now, the
interesting thing about this book is it
was back in 1902.
Okay? I I've had this book probably for
the last 29 almost 30 years. This very
book in my library. I've read this book
and it's amazing because the very book
that Chaser is drawing from the Miles is
drawing from Kaser that Miles says
Adventists have no clue what they're
they're arguing against or criticizing.
Oh, I've got the book that Kaser's gone
to and I've had this book for many
years. So, it's nothing new about that.
Right? This teaching is nothing new
which I said in the presentation.
One of the central tenants of my claim
about this being the strongest argument
against 7th day Sabotarianism is
precisely that this argument is ancient.
It's not modern. And no, it didn't
originate with John's Parker's The
Sabbath transferred either. I'm
obviously aware of this book and I cite
it in the presentation as well as on our
website. We're going to look at it here
in a little bit. Jeff, Christians have
been dealing with your guys' arguments
long before the inception of Adventism
because your guys's arguments for the
binding validity of the Seventh Day
Sabbath aren't new either. But with
regards to him saying that I'm following
the teachings of Dr. Kaiser. Yes,
because Jeff Dr. Kaiser is a
Presbyterian.
I'm a Presbyterian. I'm glad that I
could catch you up to speed on this, but
there's this denomination out there
called the Presbyterians.
Some of them refer to themselves as the
Reformed branch of the Protestant
Reformation. They have this confession
called the Westminster Confession of
Faith. And that confession has a chapter
about the Sabbath.
Philip Kaiser is simply in line with
that.
What Dr. Kaiser puts forth in his book
is not novel to him. He didn't originate
any of it.
Yet, Jeff says this like he uncovered
something when I literally bring up
slides in the presentation citing
Kaiser's book. And I'm very open about
such. I also didn't learn this from him,
Jeff. I already held my position prior
to even reading Kaiser's book.
I would actually attribute uh Master
John Owen largely to convincing me of
this from scripture. And he wasn't a
Presbyterian.
Kaiser is only one of numerous
individuals that I've read on this and
they are all appealing to the biblical
text, not themselves. What you really
need to do is deal with what Kaiser and
Parker's biblical arguments are.
I used Kaiser's book in my presentation
for the same reason I use any scholar
that I reference. And I'm very open on
this platform about why I cite
scholarship.
Because my intent is to show people this
isn't answering Adventism's private
interpretation and to let them weigh the
evidence for themselves.
I specifically utilized Dr. Kaiser on
this because his book explains the
subject in a very easy to digest
fashion, unlike some of the 16th century
works that I like which are a little
antiquated in their wording and they're
harder for the modern listener to
understand.
But if he would have actually shown
where Dr. Kaiser refers to John's
Parker, by the way, it's on something he
pointed out regarding the Greek language
in a specific text of scripture. So
really, the focus is on scripture. It's
what John's Parker uh that's what John's
Parker is pointing to about the Greek.
And the question should be, is what he's
pointing out correct or incorrect?
Because it's a serious argument that
carries a whole ton of weight if true.
Notice
this is with regards to the Greek in
Acts uh 13. Okay.
Quote, when Paul and Barnabas were in
Antioch in Pacidia on their first
missionary tour, we have the most
indisputable evidence of the transfer of
the Sabbath from Saturday to Sunday.
Halt right there. Does that sound like
in the title of the book name that
John's Parker and Philip Kaiser are
saying that in Genesis it was a Sunday
Sabbath? Remember that folks,
just remember that the title of this
book is the Sabbath transferred,
which would imply they're not saying
that it was Sunday in the Genesis week.
Again, remember that. But he continues,
"Paul first preached to the Jews in
their synagogue on the Jewish Sabbath.
And when the Jews were gone out of their
synagogue, Acts 13:42, the Gentiles
besought that these words might be
preached to them the next Sabbath."
And he has the Greek there, which
essentially he he renders out and says
could be in the Sabbath in between, that
is the Sabbath between the Jewish
Sabbaths.
Did you catch that?
Acts 13:42.
Some Greek grimarans have argued
that what's being said there is that
Paul brought the gospel to the Gentiles
the Sabbath in between the Jewish
Sabbaths.
Parker's continues and the narrative
continues. Acts 13:44. And the next
Sabbath day there he has the Greek and
he has on the following Sabbath just at
hand came almost the whole city together
to hear the word of God.
When the participle is used in reference
to place,
it designates a place that is near or
next.
As in Mark 1 138 where Christ said, "Let
us go into the next towns."
Now get this. When the participle is
used in reference to time, not place,
time, it designates the next day as in
Acts 21:26
where Paul took the men and the next day
purifying himself with them entered into
the temple. The evangelist here says the
following Sabbath
on which the Gentiles would naturally
hold religious service was between the
Jewish Sabbaths and near at hand that is
on Sunday. Can language be framed that
would prove the transfer of the Sabbath
from Saturday to Sunday more clearly and
indisputably than this language of the
inspired evangelist? Close quote.
Yeah, Jeff, John's Parker is irrelevant
to the substance of what's being
presented here. He didn't originate the
Greek language and write the Bible. He
simply highlights a fact that one must
weigh the thrust of for themselves.
Dr. Kaiser points out that for him, he
thinks Parker's was a little too
dogmatic here. I tend to agree. If this
is the only thing we had in scripture,
for example, eh, I don't know if it
carries the whole case.
But thankfully we have a whole mountain
of scriptures because there are texts
outside of the first day ones that can
be analyzed. Hebrews 4, Romans 14, etc.
There's far more on this and this goes
back to what I was saying about, you
know, Adventists are so used to the
individual leoty is typically used to
arguing these individual Acts 20:17, you
know, these single first day passages.
Shoot. No, that that's that is down the
list of other things like I showed in
the presentation.
But for those that want access to this
book, go to the link in the description
box. There's an article there that's
linked and it's for an article on our
website titled Is Sunday the Christian
Sabbath? This quote is there and the
citation is in red which means it's
hyperl. So click on it. Go look into his
arguments for yourself because it's
going to send you to the Bible. not
John's Parker's private opinions.
But what's fascinating is that this
belief and teaching isn't unique to
Presbyterians. Jeff, I've cited numerous
individuals of various Christian
traditions that believed and taught this
same thing from scripture. They all saw
it from scripture. That article I just
mentioned included many of them. So,
you'll see that there if you go check
the article out.
Adventists tend to adore Adam Clark,
Methodist theologian. Well, Clark
believed and taught the same thing as a
Methodist. Just look at his commentary
on Colossians 2, for example.
Commenting on Colossians 2:16, Clark
says, quote,
"There is no intimation here that the
weekly Sabbath was done away or that its
moral use was superseded by the
introduction of Christianity.
I've shown elsewhere that remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy is a command
of perpetual obligation and can never be
superseded but by the final termination
of time
as it is a type of that rest which
remains for the people of God of an
eternity of bliss. It must continue in
full force till that eternity arrives
for no type ever ceases till the
antitype become.
Besides it's not clear that the apostle
refers at all to the Sabbath in this
place whether Jewish or Christian.
His of Sabbaths or weeks most probably
refers to the feasts of weeks of which
much has been said in the notes on the
Pentatuk. Close quote. Yeah, this is
before John's Parker's book a century
prior.
Now whether you agree with Clark or not
is not the point. I don't agree with
Adam Clark on a lot of stuff. I'm not a
Methodist. The point is is that Adam
Clark as a Methodist believed the same
thing myself, Philip Kaiser, Philip
Schoff, and countless others do.
Adam Clark was not a 7th day sabotarian
or a Presbyterian. He was a Christian
sabotarian.
And he recognized that the weekly
Sabbath is a memorial.
The day is a memorial. It's not the
substance. It's the memorial that points
to the eternal rest of God.
That's what we mean when we say the
phrase God's rest. That's what the
weekly Sabbath points to and is a
memorial of. But once we arrive at that
consummation state, once we enter into
eternity with God, well, that memorial
is no longer necessary. We'll then be in
the antitype. But until then, the
memorial continues.
Jumping back to the 17th century, long
before Philip Kaiser, John's Parker,
Philip Schoff, and Adam Clark, William
twice,
the SDA publication review and Herald
has actually cited this book when they
thought it helped their case for the
claim that the weekly Sabbath is morally
binding and perpetual. Except William
Twice wasn't a seventh day sabotarian.
In his book, the morality of the fourth
commandment, he says, quote, the analogy
between the Jewish Sabbath and our
Christian Sabbath, consisting in two or
three particulars.
One, as on the seventh day, God rested
from six day the sixth day's work of
creation in remembrance of which benefit
the Sabbath was instituted in the Old
Testament. So in the first day of the
week after Christ by his death and
passion had accomplished the mystery of
our redemption, he returned gloriously
as a conqueror from the dead in
remembrance of which benefit the first
day of the week is celebrated in the New
Testament.
Two, as in the Old Testament, the
Sabbath was instituted that it might be
a memorial of their deliverance out of
Egypt. Deuteronomy 5:15.
So in the New Testament, the Lord's day
is a memorial of our spiritual
deliverance out of the kingdom and
captivity of Satan, procured unto us by
the resurrection of Christ, a type
whereof was that deliverance of the
children of Israel out of Egypt. And
three, by Christ's death and
resurrection were abregated Levitical
ceremonies and legal shadows amongst
which the Sabbath is reckoned.
Colossians 21:17. Therefore,
the change of the Sabbath into the
Lord's day is a public testimony that
Christians are freed from legal shadows.
Close quote.
This is why I say I don't care what
phrase you use, Christian Sabbath, first
day, Sabbath, Lord's Day, we mean the
same thing.
But Adventists like Jeff are free to
disagree with twice.
The point is that these individuals are
individuals that his own SDA pioneers
stole all their Sabbath arguments from,
but then tried claiming but but but they
were wrong about the day.
All their arguments about the per
perpetuity of the Sabbath are correct.
They're right about all this other stuff
about the Sabbath, but but but but
they're wrong about the day.
Yeah. Tell us you don't know what you're
talking about without telling us you
don't know what you're talking about.
all as if all these Christian
sabotarians had hadn't thought about
this remedial aspect of the subject.
Twice recognized the new creation just
like Adam Clark did that the Sabbath is
rooted in creation
and redemption and in the new creation
Jesus entered his rest the first day.
Jeff, you need to get this. You claimed
you've read these books. You should
understand this and why your questions
that we're about to hear are completely
irrelevant to to as some brain buster.
There's two creation accounts in focus
when it comes to the Sabbath, folks.
There's the creation exhilo in Genesis
where God brought matter out of nothing.
There's then the recreation of that
creation which fell into sin where God
entered his rest a different day.
We're not in the old creation anymore,
Jeff. We're in the new creation. God in
the old creation. Exnahilo entered his
rest the seventh day. In the new
creation, he entered the first day.
The fact that you guys can't see this or
think it's some crazy thing, especially
when you guys your whole system is built
on this wild typology.
You guys are like supposed to be the
kings of typology. Everything is some
esqueological typology in the Old
Testament about the end times.
Yet you bring up something like this and
you'll get, "That's the worst argument
I've ever heard." Yeah, it sounds like a
guilty conscience, buddy.
When the redemption of the creation that
fell was accomplished,
that was the first day, the resurrection
day. The freedom from slavery in Egypt
was a type of the bondage and slavery to
sin that we are all in. And Jesus is
leading a better exodus out of that.
That's memorialized by the first day
when God entered his rest in the new
creation. Jeff, not the seventh.
Hinrich Wolf.
He was a Hebrew professor in Zurich,
Switzerland during the Reformation. This
is cited in uh Nicholas Bound's book,
the uh I would argue probably the the
best book on this subject, the most
exhaustive work, his book, the the true
doctrine of the Sabbath. He writes,
quote, "Christ did appoint the new
Sabbath. When our last enemy, death,
being overcome, he made an end of the
labors of our redemption, which in his
humanity were to be born. And the next
day, with the new man restored, he
brought out of the grave a new time, the
time of our redemption, and of the new
covenant, and did prepare an everlasting
Sabbath into uh uh into the which
himself then entered
for us also at the time appointed by
virtue of his resurrection to be entered
into.
Therefore, as in the time of the
creation, that day which was first of
the creation finished was made holy for
the worship of God, so now in the time
of redemption,
that day which is first after the
finishing of it is to be accounted holy
of us.
Close quote.
This is what Hebrews 4 is saying. If one
simply follows the flow of the epistle
and understands that the overarching
theme is the lesser to the greater,
it covers all sorts of things like Jesus
being superior to the angels, a superior
priest, a superior Moses and Joshua,
etc. And in that we also see the author
mentioned the lesser to the greater with
regards to the old covenant and the new
covenant, the old creation and the new
creation.
More on Hebrews 4 later, but once again,
not unique to Dr. Philip Kaiser.
Church historian Dr. Philip Schoff in
his history of the Christian religion
volume 3. SDA scholarship seems to love
Philip Schoff when they think he helps
their case. Pay close attention here,
Jeff.
Quote,
"The observance of Sunday originated in
the time of the apostles
and ever since forms the basis of public
worship with its enobling uh sanctifying
and cheering influences in all Christian
lands. The Christian Sabbath is on the
one hand the continuation and the
regeneration of the Jewish Sabbath based
upon God's resting from the creation and
upon the fourth commandment of the
decalogue which as to its substance
is not of merely national application
like the ceremonial and civil law but of
universal import and perpetual validity
for mankind. Pause.
I'm going to talk about this a lot
tonight.
Notice Schoff's distinction between the
substance
and ceremony.
That's going to become very important.
Very important. I brought it up in both
of the presentations that Jeff
referenced, and I'm going to talk about
it a lot more tonight, and I'm going to
show you from scripture.
There is a substance and that substance
is not only applicable to the national
Israelites.
The ceremonial form and civil aspect
was part of a certain dispensation and
that could change. That's not the
universal part. The universal part is
the substance. Remember this.
It is on the other hand a new creation
talking about the the Christian Sabbath.
of the gospel a memorial of the
resurrection of Christ and of the work
of redemption completed and divinely
sealed thereby.
It rests we may say upon the three-fold
basis of the original creation, the
Jewish legislation and the Christian
redemption and is rooted in the
physical, the moral and the religious
wants of our nature.
The Christian Sabbath is the ancient
Sabbath baptized with fire and the Holy
Ghost regenerated, spiritualized, and
glorified. It is the connecting link of
creation and redemption of paradise lost
and paradise regained and a pledge and
preparation for the saints everlasting
rest in heaven. Just like Adam Clark
said, the ancient church viewed the
Sunday mainly, we may say, one-sidedly
and exclusively from its Christian
aspect as a new institution and not in
any way as a continuation of the Jewish
Sabbath. It observed it as the day of
the commemoration of the resurrection or
of the now spiritual creation
and hence as a day of sacred joy and
thanksgiving standing in bold contrast
to the days of humiliation and fasting
as the Easter festival contrast with
Good Friday.
Close quote.
Jeff is going to bring up his objections
around the phrase Jewish Sabbath over
and against Christian Sabbath later. So,
I'll get to what Shaw and Christian
sabotarians mean by this after we hear
Mr. Dael. But in my presentation
regarding Mark Finley and his ridiculous
claims about why Christians worship on
Sunday, I showed this statement from
Shaw. And I proceeded to show a large
swath of scriptures from Genesis to
Revelation, not single proof texts, no
large swaths of scripture that prove
what Schoff is highlighting of the
Sabbath being rooted in creation, rest,
and redemption.
It's also why I cited the church fathers
in the same presentation to show that
the seeds of this understanding are
ancient, not modern.
And you're free to disagree with them.
I'm not saying because they're ancient,
they're right. That's not my point. I'm
simply explaining that this is not new
or modern. And my position is not only
biblical, but the seeds of its
understanding are ancient. It's honestly
just the logical continuation of
studying the new creation more deeply in
scripture.
The early church understood the roots,
but they had other focuses they had to
hammer out like Christology. They didn't
dig in as far on this subject as others
did later on.
So, people have been studying this
doctrine deeply long before the Seventh
Day Adventist.
It's not some lost truth that they bear
and have a monopoly on. Their view of
the Sabbath is very truncated. It's
anemic. It's warped because they have an
extra biblical worldview called the
great controversy theme that skews
everything in the Bible, especially the
Sabbath. But Jeff, you can stop saying
that this is a regurgitation of Kaiser.
I used him for a specific reason in the
presentation, but nothing in his book
was unique or novel to him. Not the idea
of Adam and Eve's first day being God's
seventh,
or the point that was being made by my
chart, which was a redemptive historical
visual aid, which he's going to bring up
here momentarily. But did you notice
that his, you know, his jab at Dr.
Kaiser for having degrees?
Oh, no.
Dr. Kaiser, believe it or not, has
degrees. Shocking, I know. Yeah, Jeff,
that tends to be what happens when you
carry the title of PhD.
And oh no, he studied philosophy.
Yeah, because believe it or not,
philosophy is not an icky word. Believe
it or not, it's beneficial for
Christians, especially those holding the
office of sacred desk like Dr. Kaiser.
It's important that they understand
world views that are not their own and
ways of thinking outside of their own
because we have this mission and command
called the great commission that we care
about. You know, we're trying to reach
people that might think differently than
we do and better understand their ways
of thinking. And doing such can help us
better understand how to reach them.
Shocking, I know.
Believe it or not, it doesn't mean Dr.
Kaiser was indoctrinated in like worldly
or pagan philosophy,
which is basically what Jeff's statement
rire of. I can't tell you if you're not
a former Adventist, you may not pick up
on that, but there's just in some
pockets of Adventism, there's just this
sort of downplaying of education and
like, see, he you can't trust them
because they're educated.
Yeah. Okay. But Christian, let this be
an example for you of how formal
theological training is oftentimes
downplayed by SDAs. This stems back to
their Millerite roots which also put
forth the same idea that because William
Miller was essentially Bible illiterate.
They have to try and you know say like
they're they're still born out of
Millerism and they have these
connections and roots back to Millerism.
So they can't just completely cut him
off, which is why they've tried to
rebrand him as an American reformer,
not a false prophet with that shouldn't
have been doing what he was doing.
Completely unqualified, you know, just
sitting around with his Bible in a
concordance. Completely Bible
illiterate. And his interpretation was
just common sense. It was common sense.
Even though no one was thinking these
things before him. Yeah. And we see how
that worked out. Jeff, guess what? All
the 7th Day Adventist professors I had
at SDA University, they had degrees,
even the religion professors, many of
whom studied at non SDA seminaries.
He took umbrage with me, saying that
Adventists aren't equipped to deal with
uh these arguments. And then he says he
owns John's Parker's book which is
supposed to refute my claim that the
standard SDA arguments against this
position evidence that they don't know
what they're actually arguing against.
Jeff, your claim is going to age like
milk
because you yourself will prove that
this is true despite your claim that you
own John's Parker's book which was
supposed to prove that means you know
the arguments. Apparently, that's what
you're trying to like lead on with.
It was also proven in my presentation.
You're quoting because I said the
statement in question prior to laying
out the position and then listening to
Doug Bachelor present the standard SDA
arguments against the position, which
showed how they don't even engage the
arguments. Doug Bachelor burns a bunch
of straw men. That's why the thumbnail
says what it says.
Just because you own John's Parker's
book doesn't therefore mean you
understand the arguments. Again, it's
going to be made abundantly clear that
you do not.
Nothing new at all. But now notice
Kaser, if you get into some of his
material, he refers to Sunday, the first
day of the week, as the first day
Sabbath in contrast with the seventh day
Sabbath. Okay. Now, remember what Miles
talks about? He's going to get into this
new creation. That's kind of his drive.
this new creation. The motivation for
his his study particular on this subject
tonight we're going to look at. So he
says Adventists have no clue or idea of
this new creation. So we're going to see
that's his main thrust is this new
creation.
Yes, Jeff, because I'm a Christian. The
new creation refers to the new covenant,
the work of redemption that Jesus
accomplished. His rule and reign is the
second Adam that did what the first Adam
failed to do and how Jesus came and
redeemed what man broke. Yes, that's the
thrust of my foundation as a Christian
because I believe the Bible and I have a
Christian worldview, not an
extra-biblical great controversy
worldview which is not derived from
scripture. Now, I don't know if Jeff is
in this camp, but countless Adventists
have tried telling me the new creation
is a Roman Catholic doctrine. No, Rome
just happens to be in accordance with
the Bible on this. So, if that's you,
don't engage in the genetic fallacy,
also known as the guilt by association
fallacy. But yes, I stand by my claim
that Adventist theology does not
understand the new creation,
because I said this in the context of
Doug Bachelor's arguments, which plainly
evidenced as much. Every week, every
week I hear arguments from Adventists
that prove such because Doug's arguments
weren't unique to him. He simply was the
example I used. I explained how the
Sabbath is rooted in rest, creation, and
redemption. And since it's rooted in
creation, we have to discuss both old
and new creation when discussing the
subject of the Sabbath.
both the original creation in the
beginning as well as the recreation of
that creation in the redemption of
Christ.
And since Adventist theology doesn't
understand the Sabbath's root in
redemption, the new creation,
and God entering his rest, a new day in
that creation, they're illquipped to
deal with the arguments. But he said,
"Kaiser refers to Sunday as the first
day Sabbath." Yes, Jeff. The title of my
presentation was literally in defense of
the first day Sabbath. It's like I found
it odd that he says this stuff like he's
uncovering something that I wasn't
forthright about.
One can just go watch the presentation
and see none of this stuff is hidden.
Kaiser didn't originate that term, Jeff.
We don't care if you say first day
Sabbath, Lord's Day, the Christian
Sabbath. Doesn't matter. Various people
have used various phrases down through
history. In substance, we mean the same
thing regarding what the terminology is
getting at.
I use the phrase first day Sabbath
because I refuse to confir uh to concede
the term Sabbath to Adventism since it's
biblical.
They don't have a monopoly on this
subject
and it's provocative in the context of
Adventist apologetics. And I want to
provoke people to intrigue. I want to
provoke former Adventists who hear me
say I affirm the Sabbath and cause them
to go, "Hold up. Wait, what?" And I want
them to start listening because I stand
by my position being biblical and the
most glorifying position to God. I don't
want people to have a tainted view of
the Sabbath because of cult groups like
Adventism that have misused and abused
it for their own novel worldview and end
times paranoia.
Now, here's the paradigm that Miles goes
by, and he got that from Dr. Queser. So,
tonight's going to be kind of like
educational. We're going to see where he
got some of his ideas. And this paradigm
here, Miles got from Quaser. And Queser
had read also John's subject on the
transfer of the Sabbath, which was 1902.
Okay. Now in this paradigm, this is
Miles's main thought copying you might
say from Tacer is this paradigm presents
seven key points. The first four are
rooted in the last three. So the first
one is God's week. The second is man's
pre-fall week. The third is man's
postfall week. And number four is
Jesus's restoration. Five creation, six
rest, and seven redemption. Now the next
few nights or next few meetings, we're
going to cover God's week, number one.
Then man's pre-fall week. That'll be a
meeting. And then man's postfall week,
an entire meeting. and then Jesus's
restoration, an entire meeting, and then
we're going to summarize the last three
in videos. However, what's interesting
is that we're going to break down each
one of these weeks individually in a
whole presentation because Miles, he
matter of fact, he was bragging about he
popped this on a Seventh Day Adventist
pastor and this pastor was a loss for
words or didn't understand or didn't
know what it was or how to how to refute
it. And so Miles kind of was bragging
about that very thing.
No, Jeff, I didn't get this paradigm
from Dr. Kaiser.
You kept repeating this and you're
wrong. Like I already said, I already
held my view before even reading Dr.
Kaiser's book. And Dr. Kaiser didn't
originate this either because the the
chart that I showed is compiled based
off of biblical observations.
Folks, go watch the presentation. The
chart was also a visual aid to help
visual learners better understand what I
was saying and not be confused.
Jeff, if you think Dr. Kaiser originated
this, then you're only further proving
the point that you aren't informed on
this subject.
Notice, folks, he's not actually playing
any of my presentation. He's taking
screenshots of it and then commenting
over it, which allows him to put his own
spin on things, which is always
fascinating because this is what I'm
constantly accused of by Adventists.
Despite the fact that I actually let
them speak for themselves before
responding, he's not doing that.
This also isn't really a paradigm, Jeff.
The seven things you claimed make up the
paradigm
are really just different categories
that have to do with making sure one has
a fully orbed view of the Sabbath and
not a truncated one that only latches on
to certain aspects of redemptive
history.
Again, I opened the presentation by
clearly stating that I would be giving a
redemptive historical analysis on the
doctrine.
And I said this isn't a sound bites and
proof text topic because it's not. It
spans Genesis to Revelation.
All seven categories that he showed
cover the span of Genesis to Revelation,
which is a story of redemptive history.
So sure, if you want to call that a
paradigm, go ahead. It's a biblical
paradigm, and I like that a lot better
than your extra biblical great
controversy one. But with regards to the
claim that I was bragging about popping
this argument on an SDA pastor, again,
no, Jeff, I said this in the context of
showing how most Adventists haven't
heard these arguments, and it caused
this pastor to be so intrigued, he
wanted to stay in contact. That's not me
bragging, sir. It was a case sample to
support my claim that you yourself tried
implying isn't true because you own
John's Parker's book. It was a support
statement for my claim. So, I wasn't
just making an assertion.
We're going to be listening for when you
actually address the biblical arguments
found in his book,
which are what truly matter, not you
referring to his book and claiming that
Kaiser and myself are just parrots of
Parker's own private thinking. We care
about what the biblical text and what
Luke wrote in Acts, for example. Not
what I want to be there, but what did
Luke, the inspired evangelist, intend to
communicate. So, I'm going to be
attentively listening for when you deal
with those arguments.
So, this is basically the paradigm in
which Miles tries to prove a first day
Sunday Sabbath. Now, Miles admits
according to the chart in God's first
week before the fall of man is the
seventh day Sabbath in creation. God's
Sabbath on the seventh day, the seventh
day, God rested, blessed, and
sanctified. Why wouldn't man's seventh
day be God's seventh day instead of a
different seventh day than God's
according to the weekly cycle from
creation? Now, it's best to look at this
carefully because I'm going to go into
it in detail in a minute. This is just
kind of in the forefront here. So, like
I said, go back and read the questions,
answer the questions.
All right. So, notice what his question
was.
God's Sabbath on the seventh day. The
seventh day God rested, blessed, and
sanctified. Why wouldn't man's seventh
day be God's seventh day instead of a
different seventh day than God's
according to the weekly cycle of
creation?
Jeff, did did you did you bother to look
at the chart while I was explaining this
in the video?
I I I mean, wow. Adam and Eve were not
there on day 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
How could it have been Adam and Eve's
seventh day if Adam and Eve didn't exist
on days 1, 2, 3, 4, five?
That's what the chart is visually
representing. It's the same creation
week.
The whole point was that you need to
prove that it was their seventh day and
how a one-day old individual can be
seven days old.
I I'd love for you to to explain this
for us, sir. Explain for us how a
one-day old human can be seven days old.
Let's hear it. Let's hear it. On top of
that,
I said that some of you don't read
carefully enough.
I I know you guys think you're masters
of the Sabbath. Everyone else is
clueless.
But that thinking is going to get you
into trouble here. It wasn't their
seventh day, sir. Because they were one
day old on the seventh day of creation.
That's what the chart is showing. It's
just a visual aid. I explained all of
this. So, why are you asking this
question, claiming I wouldn't answer
your questions like you're going to hear
him say, thinking this is some slam dunk
for you? You seem to think you know my
position, which should mean you should
know why this question isn't at all
problematic.
Based on evening to evening as the
measuring stick,
man's first day would have been God's
seventh.
They started their week in holy
communion with God before then going out
to obey the command to subdue the earth
and be fruitful and multiply.
They would have then done that same
thing seven days from that first holy
communion with God. This is actually a
picture of the prefall disposition of
man toward God that Jesus as the second
Adam rightly restores and returns us to.
He didn't just redeem the physical
creation.
He redeemed all of the blessings of
creation that also became tainted of
which the Sabbath is a part. Resting in
perfect communion with God.
I'm going to talk more about this later
and I don't want to get ahead of myself,
but Jeff, your question poses zero
problems for my position because you
misunderstood what needed to be
demonstrated by someone that holds your
position.
Because in my presentation, I addressed
numerous objections to my position and
demonstrated why they are invalid. So,
you need to deal with my objections and
explain how they're incorrect, not just
throw questions back at me.
So, I look forward to you explaining for
us how God's seventh day could have been
Adam and Eve's when they didn't exist
for six days prior.
This is just simple basic observation
from the text that doesn't require any
degrees.
Once that's recognized, I simply ask,
okay, is that an important detail that
could potentially be teaching us
something or is it just a random
meaningless detail?
Folks, I'm going to tell you, the more
that you read the Bible, the more you
learn the Bible is to be studied, not
just read. There's a difference. And you
quickly learn all this stuff in here is
important. It's not just meaningless.
This stuff matters. It has a point. And
I explained that in the presentation.
I'm going to talk a little bit about
that later. But Jeff, you said this
apologetic is the uh you said if this
apologetic is the strongest against your
position, you'd love to see what weak
is. So, this should be a cakewalk for
you, especially considering you insist
you understand the position you're
criticizing. Explain for us how a
one-day old can be seven days old. I got
to hear this.
Continue to go from there. Now, the new
creation doesn't change the weekly cycle
according to the Bible. The Bible says
that all scriptures inspired by God and
that includes the scripture that
determines the week and each day in the
weekly cycle. In my presentation, I will
demonstrate and establish that this
premise, a Sunday, first day Sabbath in
Genesis is a false premise, a false
presupposition and cannot stand under
close scrutiny. I'm going to establish
that in these next few meetings starting
tonight. So, here's the paradigm.
Remember, this is the four key paradigm
he has here. God's week, man's pre-fall
week, and man's postfall week, and
Jesus's restoration. So contemplate this
diagram, contemplate this paradigm,
contemplate this chart, look at it
carefully, very carefully. So answering
the critics from the Bible one point at
a time. So tonight's presentation, we're
going to look at God's week. We're going
to look at it carefully based upon not
what I'm saying, based upon what Miles
is saying about the very paradigm he's
using to show the first day Sunday
Sabbath. Okay? So in his paradigm, God's
week shows that there is the seventh day
Sabbath in the Genesis account of
creation. And they call it that. It's
God's Sabbath. They call it God's
Sabbath, the seventh day. So let's take
a careful look. Let's break it down.
We're going to enlarge it. We're going
to break it down. Let's take a careful
look at the critics's chart and break it
down one point at a time. Now, according
to his chart, the seventh day is God's
Sabbath. According to Critics's charts,
God's week ends with the seventh day
Sabbath. God's Sabbath. and they call it
that. I agree with that. That's what
SDAs believe that God's seventh day
Sabbath is in creation and is at the end
of the week, the last day of the week.
We do believe that. We believe that very
thing right there. Now, in Philip
Kaser's book, here's what he has to say.
Christ's interpretation when he declares
that the Sabbath was made for mankind,
Mark 2:27, set in the context of
creation. So far, I could agree with
that. Can't you? We go to creation for
the seventh day Sabbath right in
creation. He's quoting Mark 2:27 said in
the context of creation man not being
made for the Sabbath but the Sabbath
being made for man. Now notice what he
says carefully. Christ seems to agree
that the Sabbath was observed as a
creation ordinance when mankind was
made. So he's saying see Jesus agrees
with that fact that the Sabbath was in
creation for mankind. Now notice what he
says. If this is true, then all attempts
to treat the Sabbath as an institution
unique to Israel are eliminated. That
means you can't use the argument that
the Sabbath was just for the Jew if it
was a creation ordinance back in
Genesis. That's what he's saying. So
don't call it the Jewish Sabbath then if
it indeed is for all mankind from
creation in Genesis chapters 1 and 2. So
how do you understand this statement?
Now if somebody's watching this, here's
what I would say. Here's what he says
and here's the question I'm asking. How
do you understand this statement? Write
it down on a piece of paper. Answer the
question. How do you understand this
statement? Okay, remember he said if
this is true, then all attempts to treat
the Sabbath as an institution unique to
Israel. In other words, for Israel only,
for the Jews only are eliminated. Yes,
it would be eliminated because the
Sabbath is in creation. This is what
he's arguing right here. So, I'm going
to go to the very text he uses, Mark
chapter 2. Watch this carefully.
Remember what I said about answering the
questions. That's my challenge to the
viewers. Just simply answer the
questions. Now remember Jesus said he
said unto them the Sabbath. So now you
have the Sabbath mentioned in Mark 2:27.
Therefore the son of man is Lord of the
Sabbath. You have the Sabbath mentioned
right there in Mark 227 and 28. Chapter
2 27 28. Here's my question. Is this
Sabbath made for man in creation? Answer
the question. That's it. Just answer the
question. Is this Sabbath right here?
Made for man in creation. Here's the
next question. Is this God's Sabbath,
the Sabbath that is the seventh day in
Genesis 2:es 2 and 3? Is it? Write your
answer down. Or is this Israel's Sabbath
just for the Jews? Answer the question.
So here you have Ker saying that the
Sabbath if it's true, then the Sabbath
is in creation and that's for all
mankind, not just the Jews. So it
wouldn't be unique to Israel and the
Jews only. Okay. So is this Israel
Sabbath just for the Jews right here?
Is this Israel Sabbath just for the Jews
the same seventh day in the weekly cycle
as God's seventh day in creation in the
weekly cycle?
Answer the question.
Is this seventh day in creation that
determines and governs each and every
day in the weekly cycle according to the
New Testament? The New Testament.
his slide said and he said the new
creation didn't change the weekly cycle.
Right. And Jeff, this was never claimed.
And because you thought something was
being said that wasn't,
you then built your questions on that
errant foundation.
I simply pointed out that Adam and Eve
were not there on days one, two, three,
four, and five. And that on day six,
they wouldn't have experienced evening
to evening, which would have made the
evening of the seventh day the end of
their first day. Nothing about the new
creation changing the weekly cycle.
Again, the chart, notice the annotations
at the top right, folks.
Before
the fall, man started the week on the
Sabbath. After the fall, man ended his
week on the Sabbath. After redemption,
man starts the week on the Sabbath
again.
Not that there are three literal
different weeks or that there became a
new weekly cycle with the new creation.
No, there's a new day that God entered
his rest after the second creation work.
the work of recreation, redemption. And
I'm going to keep hammering this in
hopes that you get it. Jesus entered his
rest the first day, sir, not the
seventh.
That was God in the old creation. In the
new creation, God entered his rest on
the first day. We're in the new creation
now, not the old creation. 2 Corinthians
5 proves this. It's here
again. It's like, sir, you claim to have
studied this out. You should be engaging
with this reality. You're not doing
that. You're posing a bunch of questions
you think are a bunch of gotchas as if
people haven't thought about this
before. Are you kidding yourself?
There's two creation acts. God entered
his rest two different times.
both in the original exhilo creation act
but then also after the redemption of
that act or or of of that creation
but as it pertains to my claims about
man's week beginning on the seventh day
in order to demonstrate your claim
against this Jeff
you must demonstrate that Adam and Eve
were present from day one of creation
until then you haven't falsified the
Christian sabotarian position but notice
that he says a Sunday, first day Sabbath
in Genesis. I pointed this out earlier,
Jeff. I never used this language to
describe Genesis.
I've never said this. I never said that
in the presentations that you referenced
previously. In fact, in part two, we're
going to listen to how Jeff makes a big
deal about me saying that Adventists
read the word Saturday into the seventh
day in Genesis. But what he doesn't
mention is that I also say it doesn't
say Sunday either.
And I was making a very specific point
in saying that in conjunction with
highlighting that Adam and Eve's first
day was God's seventh.
Obviously, John's Parker and Philip
Kaiser and everyone else are not
claiming what you claim that we believe
when the book title of his book is the
Sabbath transferred. Sir, we're not
saying a Sunday Sabbath in creation like
it was God's seventh day, but it was
Adam and Eve's Sunday. That's what
Jeff's trying to put forth here as the
argument.
No, that's not what's being said at all.
Again, I was making a very specific
point
that in conjunction with highlighting
that Adam and Eve's first day was God's
seventh.
This detail is actually important when
you do a redemptive historical analysis
of the doctrine of the Sabbath.
The first Adam
was in holy communion with God on his
first day.
Based on evening to evening, man was
created on the sixth day and his first
day would have technically been the
seventh day of the creation week. The
first Adam then sins and plunges the
creation into sin.
The second Adam, Jesus Christ, he comes
to fix what man broke, Jeff, and he
redeems it. In doing so, he actually
paralleled God in the original exnilo
creation act by also doing a creation
work.
The work of redeeming the creation that
fell and making it new. This is the new
creation.
He accomplished that work in full just
like God did in the original creation.
And then after he finished this new
creation, he ceased or rested just like
God in creation, the original creation,
he sabbaththed.
Sabbath means rest or cease.
But unlike God in the original creation,
the Genesis creation, God in Christ
entered his rest on the first day, the
resurrection day, to then return back to
holy communion with God in the heavenly
places after he resurrected in a
glorified body. It comes full circle,
sir.
Mankind began their first day in holy
communion. that breaks. The second Adam
then comes and returns us back to that
by redeeming us and making us new
creatures in Christ. 2 Corinthians 5.
And as the second Adam, he entered into
God's rest the first day, just like the
first Adam entered God's rest on his
first day.
I was giving a redemptive historical
presentation on the doctrine of the
Sabbath. Jeff,
this minor detail in Genesis is not
arbitrary. It's why I then went on to
talk about preparation day in Exodus
being day six and that not being
arbitrary.
These things are not being read into the
text by Philip Kaiser or answering
Adventism. They are simple facts based
on observation.
And if you're willing to think they're
not arbitrary details, you'll learn that
they actually are teaching you
something.
It's like day six for Israel being
preparation day before then entering
into the Sabbath was not some arbitrary
thing that's based on creation. Day six
was preparation day in the creation
week. Man was prepared to then enter
into their holy convocation with God.
That's exactly what Israel was told to
do. And it was memorialized by creation.
Hello.
The seventh day was indeed the seventh
day of the week. I never denied this or
claimed it wasn't. When the chart talks
of man's week, it's not saying a new
week started when man came into
existence with God's week being
different.
That's what Jeff has errently concluded
either ignorantly or dishonestly because
I explained this.
This is why I asked if he actually
listened to me talk when he took his
screenshots of the chart or did he just
try and interpret it himself without
listening? Because I explained what this
chart was saying. And it wasn't that
Adam and Eve had a new week that came
into existence with God's week already
being in existence or that the new
creation brought about a new week. No,
it brought about a new day because God
entered his rest a new day.
I just want to make sure this is crystal
clear. Jeff, you need to demonstrate
that Adam and Eve were present from day
one. Otherwise, it wasn't their seventh
day in the creation week. Yes, it was
the seventh day of the creation week
itself. We're not denying this, but they
were not there to experience the
previous days,
which is why God's seventh was man's
first. and every day uh uh every seven
days from that first Sabbath would have
had holy communion with God. That was my
point and I explained why this matters.
This is simply one observation and point
in a larger scope of things. There is a
pattern that's being presented here and
God is teaching us something through the
order of his own activities
and man's own experience when it comes
to the creation.
Jeff gets into trying to refute this and
take major umbrage with me saying
avenist theology, you know, deifies a
24-hour rotation around the sun, but
that'll be in part two, so I'll save
more for that then. But he also said,
"We call the seventh day God's Sabbath."
Yeah, because the author of Hebrews uses
the term God's Sabbath. And it's a term
that means the eternal state, the
eternal promised land, what Canaan was
only a picture of. It's what the seventh
day pictured.
The first day is when Jesus entered into
God's Sabbath ahead of us.
Jesus is God. And this was God entering
his rest, but this time after the
accomplishment of the recreation of the
creation that fell.
There are two terms that are used for
rest in Hebrews 4. And the Greek text
shows this. The author distinguishes
between catapos
and the sabatismos,
which helps us see both the substance of
the Sabbath and the memorial that points
to that. They're not identical.
And this is going to be a thorn in Mr.
Dowel's flesh as we're going to see
because he's going to engage in the
exact thing I said in my presentation
that Adventists often do. They will
conflate the ceremonial form of the
command, the memorial aspect, with the
actual substance itself.
I'll explain that when we get to it. But
yes, we use the phrase God's Sabbath
because we believe the Bible, Jeff.
But then he posed the first question
with regards to to Mark 2:27. He asked,
"Is this Sabbath made for man in
creation?"
For starters, I reiterated the same
thing that Kaiser said in my
presentation about Mark 2:27. So why
Jeff thinks this poses some sort of
problem for us? Only evidences. He
doesn't understand what he's
criticizing. Yet he said he was going to
demolish this.
Jeff, the reformed have been using Mark
2:27 to prove the perpetuity of the
Sabbath long before the SDA movement was
even born.
And this is why I always say SDAs stole
all of their arguments for Christian Sab
uh uh for the Sabbath from Christian
sabotarians, but then they claim, well,
they were wrong about the day, though.
All the arguments that we use for the
Sabbath being perpetual or valid, but
we're completely wrong about the day.
That's basically what the S SDA is
telling us. Almost as if no one else has
deeply thought about this before.
And since I know SDA's out there will
will try and claim no, they our pioneers
were influenced by the Seventh Day
Baptists, not whoever you're referring
to. Yeah, the Seventh Day Baptists were
using arguments from Christian
Sabotarians that were around before
their movement and made this same claim.
All the Christian sabotarian arguments
are good and valid. They're just wrong
about the day, allegedly.
But here we arrive at yet another error,
and it's one I mentioned earlier. He
pointed to Mark 2:27 and asked, "Is this
Sabbath made for man in creation?" The
answer is yes, Jeff. Very obviously,
that's what Kaiser and Christian
sabotarians are arguing and agree with.
But this isn't the slam dunk that you
think it is.
You're not distinguishing between the
substance of the Sabbath over and
against its ceremonial aspects like the
day.
I I went over this in the presentation
because what Jeff is trying to claim is
that if Jesus said the Sabbath was made
for man and it's hearkening back to the
original creation account that was the
seventh day, therefore the SDA position
is the correct one. That's basically
what he's trying to get at. But no,
Jeff, you arrived at this error because
you're not distinguishing between the
substance of the Sabbath over and
against its ceremonial form. The
ceremonial form is not some eternal
substantive thing.
And it's your inability or refusal to
distinguish this fact that once again
leads you to asking questions you think
are brain busters but actually pose zero
problems. I'll talk about this more when
we look at uh Exodus 20 and Deuteronomy
5 later. But then his second question
was, "Is this God's Sabbath, the Sabbath
that is the seventh day in Genesis 2 2
uh through 3?"
Yes, Jeff, because there's only one
Sabbath. This is again your inability to
think in categories that's clouding your
thinking. The substance of the of the
Sabbath has never changed. It will never
change because it's not a day. Days are
not eternal. Days are not transcendent.
They're a part of creation.
The day is not a part of the substance,
sir.
Before the creation week, the substance
of the Sabbath was still present.
You guys should understand this as your
SDA pioneers stole this from the
reformed tradition also. But then they
twisted it by filtering it through the
great controversy theme which results in
all sorts of silliness.
God resting on the seventh day is not
the substance of the Sabbath. The
substance is actually God himself. And
the Sabbath teaches us something about
him.
There is then a memorial day given in
creation that points to that substance.
But the memorial is not the substance.
It's just like a a sign on the
interstate for a gas station. Well, is
the sign the gas station itself?
No. It's a sign that's telling you or
pointing you to the thing itself.
Mark 2:27 is also being spoken during
the old creation period.
The substance during that period of time
was the same as it always has been. In
the new creation, a ceremonial aspect of
the command has changed by virtue of God
entering his rest a different day, the
first day. And the ceremonial form not
only can change, but it does change. And
I'm going to show that later.
But I talked about all this in my
presentation, Jeff.
So you should already know this. You
should already know why this question
doesn't pose any problems for me,
especially if my position is weaker than
weak and you're allegedly going to
demolish it. Then thirdly, he asked, "Or
is this Israel's Sabbath just for the
Jews?"
And this is where Jeff demonstrates
he doesn't understand the way Christian
sabotarians are using the phrase Jewish
Sabbath.
He mentioned this phrase a little bit
earlier, but Jeff, we're not using that
phrase the way antonyomians or
dispensationalists are. It is simply a
landmark term that we use to refer to
the memorial of the Sabbath during a
specific period of redemptive history,
even prior to Israel.
But the Jewish Sabbath shared the exact
same substance as the Christian Sabbath.
No different. Israel simply missed the
substance of the Sabbath despite their
strict gatekeeping.
It's like I'm I'm I'm chuckling folks
just because it's like
I'm not laughing at them and it's sad
when I say this but it's just it's the
facts is Adventists are like the the
Israel wanderers mentioned in Hebrews 3
and4
Israel simply missed the substance of
the of the Sabbath despite their strict
daykeeping.
They wandered around in the wilderness
and didn't enter into God's rest. We're
told because they didn't believe the
gospel. Hebrews 4 2-4
yet they were observing the seventh day
which further showcases that daykeeping
is not the substance of the Sabbath.
It's a ceremonial component of it that
points us to the substance. That's what
a memorial does.
So the answer is simple. Yes. Your
errant understanding of the Sabbath is
the problem, not Mark 2:27. Then
fourthly, he asked, "Or is this Israel's
Sabbath just for the Jews the same
seventh day in the weekly cycle as God's
seventh day in creation in the weekly
cycle?" Uh the answer to which is the
same as it was to the you know the
previous ones. Yes. Because the
ceremonial form of the command isn't the
gift given by uh to man by God.
It's really about God giving himself to
us. That that's ultimately what the
substance is about. not a day. That's
why I keep saying you guys deify a 24
rota hour rotation around the sun
thinking that that's some like
transcendent eternal
thing as if that's like some core
component to to really observe the
Sabbath. You have to be going to church
on Saturday. No, dude. You're like
Israel in the wilderness. You're
completely missing it.
Jesus truly is the substance of the
Sabbath and what it's rooted in. The
memorial, the day points to that the
seventh day did in the old creation, the
first day does in the new creation. It
points to the same thing.
Then fifthly, he asked, is this the
seventh day in creation that determines
and governs each and every day in the
weekly cycle according to the New
Testament? Again, Jeff, the same as the
last few answers. It's you're not
delineating between the substance of of
the Sabbath and the ceremonial form that
accompanies it.
And the New Testament is the period in
which the new creation begins.
This doesn't mean it changed the weekly
cycle like he said earlier, but the
author of Hebrews explains this and I
went over it in the presentation he's
referencing. God and Christ in
redemption paralleled God in creation.
God did a mighty miraculous work of
creation, accomplished that work, and
entered his rest the seventh day. Jesus,
God in Christ, did a mighty miraculous
work of redeeming that creation, making
it new, accomplished that work, but then
entered his rest not on the seventh day,
the first day.
The memorial day is determined based on
when God entered his rest. Jeff, you
agree?
But you fail to to grasp that in the new
creation, God entered his rest on a
different day.
Creation, rest, and redemption. That's
what the Sabbath is rooted in.
And to truly understand this doctrine,
you have to understand all three of
those aspects and look at all of
redemptive history, not just little
cherrypicked portions that you guys look
at and then try and drag out
exhaustively beyond those. You're
missing the forest for the trees.
Basically,
Jesus did a new creation act that was
greater than that of the Genesis
creation.
Yes, the redemption of the creation from
Genesis was a greater act than the
original creation. And you have two
different days of God entering his rest.
Originally, he entered the seventh. In
redemption, he entered the first.
None of these questions are problematic
when one understands the old and new
creation and how Jesus entering his rest
the first day, just like God and
creation entered the seventh,
establishes the new memorial of the new
creation.
But that new memorial still points to
the same substance that the old creation
memorial did. It points us to God
himself. I I don't really know any other
way to say it. I said the same thing in
that presentation. That's what Hebrews 4
is saying. Notice what Thomas Watson
says on this. I've been showing this a
lot recently because it's a home run
explanation.
This is from his book, The Ten
Commandments. Long before John's Parker,
Mr. Dowel quote
now there is a grand reason for changing
of the Jewish Sabbath remember what we
mean by that to the Lord's day
because this puts us in mind of the
mystery of the redemption by Christ. The
reason why God did institute the old
Sabbath was because God would have it
kept as a memorial of the creation. But
the Lord hath now brought the first day
of the week in the room of it, in memory
of a more glorious work than creation,
and that is redemption.
What he means by that is a more glorious
work of recreation, a greater creative
work.
Great was the work of creation, but
greater was the work of redemption.
As it was said, Haggi 2:9, the glory of
the second temple was greater than the
glory of the first temple. So the glory
of the red of of the redemption was
greater than the glory of the creation.
He's just pointing to a an example of
the lesser to the greater. There's all
sorts of these in the Bible. Even that's
what I'm saying. All these details,
folks, sorry not to to sidetrack from
the the quote here, but folks, all these
details in the Bible like that, like the
first temple to the second temple, is
this just some arbitrary thing that's
happening that's documented down in the
Bible? No. There's these little nuggets
there that are teaching you something.
The glory of the second temple was
greater than the first temple. The glory
of the new creation is greater than that
of the old creation. There's all sorts
of parallels like this. That's what the
whole book of Hebrews is about.
Great wisdom was seen in the curious
making of us,
but more miraculous wisdom in saving us.
Great power was seen in bringing us out
of nothing. The creation x nahilo in
Genesis. But greater power in helping us
when we were worse than nothing.
It cost more to redeem us than to create
us.
In the creation, there was but speaking
a word. Psalm 148:5. In the redeeming of
us, there was the shedding of blood. 1
Peter 1:19.
The creation was the work of God's
finger. Psalm 8:3. Redemption was the
work of his arm. Luke 1:5. In the
creation, God gave us ourselves.
In the redemption, he gave us himself.
By creation, we have a life in Adam. By
redemption, we have a life in Christ.
Colossians 3:3. By creation, we had a
right to an earthly paradise. But by
redemption, we have a title to an
heavenly kingdom.
So that well Christ might change the
seventh day of the week into the first
because this day puts us in mind of our
redemption which is a more glorious work
than the creation.
Close quote.
Man,
this is why the resurrection is appealed
to as support for the first day Sabbath.
Mr. dowel.
It isn't just because well uh the
resurrection
and we just think that's a good thing to
remember
which is basically one of the arguments
Doug Bachelor tried making and I hear
countless Adventists argue
and it's because they don't understand
why the resurrection day is being
pointed to. And I get it. I get it folks
to be fair. I get it. I get it. Lots of
Christians do not have a deep theology
on this subject. The Bible is complex in
terms of it has all sorts of topics and
different depths and levels of of depth
on various doctrines etc. I get it. So
lots of Christians have just said well
because the resurrection day and they've
heard this from other people but that is
a summation statement. The resurrection
day is the day that God entered his rest
in the new creation. That's why that's
being said. That's why the resurrection
day is being pointed to.
That was when Jesus entered his rest and
the new creation was inaugurated.
Meaning Jesus ceased from the work of
redemption. He had accomplished it in
full.
It was not applied in full but
accomplished in full.
Meaning, so for example, part of what
Jesus accomplished in redemption is our
resurrection. But that hasn't happened
yet. So it hasn't been applied by the
Holy Spirit yet. That is a future thing
to still come. But it was all completely
accomplished at the resurrection. That's
what Paul hinges it on in 1 Corinthians
15.
But it was that first day that he ceased
from that work as the suffering servant
and entered his rest.
The evidence of Jeff not distinguishing
between the substance versus the
ceremonial aspects of the Sabbath is
that he treats the day as though it
can't change. When ceremonial aspects of
it not only can change, but they do
change in scripture as redemptive
history unfolds. Again, I'm going to
show this later.
It's also why this subject is a lot
bigger than just the original creation
act in Israel.
It's why I went to great lengths to lay
out a bigger picture than the SDA
position does. The Adventist position
has latched on to certain aspects of
redemptive history and then misses the
bigger picture in the process.
But Jeff, I have a challenge for you
regarding Mark 2:27. Okay.
This is what your prophetus had to say
regarding the Sabbath in heaven. quote,
"All heaven is keeping the Sabbath, but
not in a listless, do nothing way. On
this day, every energy of the soul
should be awake. For are we not to meet
with God and with Christ our Savior? We
may behold him by faith. He's longing to
refresh and bless every soul." Close
quote.
So Jeff Jesus in Mark 2 said that the
Sabbath was
made.
So, it isn't eternal in the sense that
you guys try and claim it is. But
furthermore, he said it was made for
who?
Man.
Not angels. Not heavenly beings, not
beings on other worlds.
Yet, your prophetus claims heavenly
beings are keeping the Sabbath when it
was made for man.
On top of that, how are they keeping the
Sabbath if days are a part of creation?
creation of the earth.
In the great controversy paradigm, you
guys teach that the ten commandments
were around before the creation of the
earth and all of heaven was following
them, which would include the Sabbath.
So, are they keeping the seventh day
Sabbath?
How if days were created when the earth
was?
You either have to say that they're
keeping the substance of it, but they're
not on the same weekly cycle that we
are, which is the defense I've heard
from numerous Adventists. To which I
say, I rest my case. Thank you for
concinged that the day is not a part of
the substance of the command and one can
keep the Sabbath apart from the seventh
day. Or you have to make the seventh day
in the creation week eternal somehow.
say the weekly cycle has eternally
existed and then poured it to heaven
where angels and spirit beings are on
the same weekly cycle that we are.
Your prophet has tried to prove too much
here
and Mark 2:27
based on what she says about Mark 2:27.
You as an Adventist pastor are bound to
uphold what she claimed here. So that's
my challenge to you on this point, Jeff.
Looking forward to your answer. see why
I asked that question because Miles a
sidekick Sam Shimone he says that he
interprets the Old Testament from the
New Testament. So we're going to go that
direction. You're going to see that in a
moment. Is this now remember I'm talking
about Mark 27:28. Is this the Sabbath
that is written in the Ten Commandments
in Exodus 20:es 8-11? So is this Sabbath
right here in Mark 227 the Sabbath that
is written in the Ten Commandments? Just
simply answer the question. This
question is for the critics. But any
viewers, if you want to do this, just
sit down and write your answers to these
questions. Is this the Sabbath that is
written in the ark of the covenant,
Revelation 11:19, and the tabernacle of
the testimony in Revelation 15:5? Is
this the Sabbath that is in those arcs,
in the ark of the covenant? Now,
remember the context. Is the Sabbath day
in Mark 2:27, the first day of the week,
the Sunday Sabbath, or the seventh day
of the week, the Saturday Sabbath, the
same seventh day according to the weekly
cycle in Genesis 1 and 2?
Is the Pharisees charging Jesus and the
disciples for breaking the first day of
the week, Sunday Sabbath, or the seventh
day of the week, the Saturday Sabbath?
Very important questions there. Very
important. Remember, Jesus said this
before he ever went to the cross, didn't
he? He made this statement before he
ever went to the cross. So, did the
Pharisees know anything about the first
day of the week, Sunday Sabbath? Did the
Pharisees keep the first day Sunday
Sabbath? Is this first day Sunday
Sabbath found written in the law of God?
So, he says Sam Shimone is my sidekick.
For those of you that know,
for those of you that know Sam in the
audience that are friends with him,
please relay that message to him. He'll
get a kick out of that.
Jeff, Sam is a friend. He's not my
sidekick,
though. I did get a good chuckle out of
that when I first heard it, and I'm
still getting cut up here.
It's really irrelevant to bring up Sam,
though, as Sam doesn't even have an
identical view to me on the Sabbath.
How's he How is he my sidekick on this?
We don't even have an identical view. we
agree in terms of the substance, but I
would just go a step further and say,
but there's still a Memorial Day that
points to that substance, which is
ultimately what the seventh day was
previously. He he would disagree and he
would well, he's actually going to bring
that up a little bit later, so I'll save
it for there. But I'm not sure why
bringing him up deals with anything in
my presentation.
But Sam was also correct in what he
mentioned there that the New Testament
interprets the Old Testament, not the
other way around.
I mean, this is just hermeneutics 101.
The New Testament is further revelation
from God that speaks to prior
revelation.
All cults have this backward, folks. All
of them. They try interpret the New
Testament in light of the Old Testament,
which is exactly what the SDA system
does. But then he asked another series
of questions, and my answer is still the
same, Jeff. Yes, because the substance
of that Sabbath is eternal and doesn't
change.
The day is not a part of the substance,
which is what Jeff is ultimately trying
to argue for. And his inability to
distinguish between the substance and
the memorial is why he thinks this is
some sort of home run that thwamps my
view and all the brilliant minds that
came before his sect. Jeff, the Sabbath
in Genesis fell on Adam and Eve's first
day. Until you're able to prove for us
that Adam and Eve were there on day 1,
2, 3, 4, and 5, you won't be able to
convince me that the seventh day of that
week was actually their seventh day
because it wasn't. And like I showed,
you also need to demonstrate how the
Sabbath in Mark 2:27,
what you're trying, you know, you're
tying the seventh day to as some sort of
eternal, unalterable, unchangeable
aspect of this eternal command.
How that seventh day was around and
functioning for all of heaven before the
earth was even created.
You need to explain why Jesus says it
was made for man. Yet your prophetus
that you're bound to yield to claimed
that angels and all sorts of beings are
keeping it. You need to explain how
they're doing so despite the weekly
cycle on earth being a part of its
creation. And you guys believe these
other creatures were around long before
the earth's creation.
But then the question about the
Pharisees, he asked, "Are the Pharisees
charging Jesus and the disciples for
breaking the first day of the week,
Sunday Sabbath, or the seventh day of
the week Sabbath?" Again, Jeff, you said
you read the book by John's Parker,
which is titled The Sabbath
Transferred.
Like I said earlier, folks, his
questions are all predicated upon his
faulty, errant understanding of what was
claimed. I never said the Sabbath in
Genesis was a first day Sunday Sabbath.
Jeff, you really need to better study
what you're criticizing. You're not
demolishing anything. You're
embarrassing yourself. It's not this
isn't the gotcha that you think it is.
And if your questions are posed at me
since I'm your reference here
and you said, you know, these are for
the critics, I'm beginning to think you
didn't actually watch my presentation
because I repeatedly explained that the
Sabbath was tainted by the fall and thus
even man's rest became tainted. He'd
have to work now by the sweat of his
brow and have to work to enter rest
versus how he started off his original
disposition in holy communion with God.
Jesus then comes and restores that
disposition.
The term first day Sabbath is not
referring to the seventh day in creation
being Sunday.
Again, he's going to make a big deal
about this in part two where he's like
he he says Adventist read Saturday into
the into Genesis
when my whole point was it doesn't say
Saturday or Sunday because that that
that's not the point and my chart was to
support what I was saying and be get
behind out of the way of all that fog
to look at a a greater point. So that
alone proves I was not saying that the
Sabbath in Genesis was Sunday and that
it was like it was God's seventh day and
it was Adam and Eve's first day. So it
was Sunday for them or something like
that.
When I said Adam and Eve's first day was
God's seventh,
I'm not saying it was Sunday for them,
but Saturday for God to use vernacular
that we would in our day. So if Jeff
actually watched attentively, he would
know my answer to this already because
Doug Bachelor used the same reasoning
that that Jeff is all Adventists do.
Yes, Jesus and the disciples observe the
memorial of the old creation. I said
this repeatedly in the presentation.
It was two parts, six hours. I said that
I don't know how many times. He even
mentioned that Jesus said what he did in
Mark 2:27. And he said these words
before the cross. Yes, before the new
creation was inaugurated and Jesus
entered his rest on the first day from
the work of recreation. I'm going to
scoot back from the mic, Jeff, and I'm
going to say it a little bit louder.
Maybe that will help you get it.
This was before the new creation was
inaugurated.
We aren't in the old creation anymore,
Jeff.
The memorial in the new creation is when
God in Christ entered his rest the first
day.
I I wish you guys would get this so you
could understand why Christians rejoice,
why we celebrate what the first day is
actually memorializing
instead of trying to say, "Well, that's
about Satan and the Pope." No, it's not.
It's why you guys aren't Christians for
the most part.
Totally confused. don't understand the
gospel. Don't understand what was
accomplished that day. Don't understand
don't understand anything about what's
going on. It's like bing and scoffing at
me earlier saying this is the paradigm
he's coming from. Yeah, cuz I'm a
Christian. I believe the gospel. I want
Adventist to understand this. That's why
I'm getting worked up.
Jesus entered his rest the first day,
not the original, not the seventh day
when God entered the original creation.
Deuteronomy 5 proves that the ceremonial
form of the commandment can change and
that there's a difference between the
ceremonial form and the substance.
The day is a part of ceremony, not
substance.
I showed all this. Why are you not
engaging with any of it? You're just
taking sound bites of what I said,
twisting it, and then posing questions
that pose zero problems for anything I I
said, knocking down a bunch of straw
men.
It does however prove that you don't
know what you're criticizing despite
insisting that you do.
So is Mark 2:27 talking about a a first
day Sunday Sabbath made for man in
creation?
Well, let's read the text in Exodus 20.
For in six days the Lord made heaven and
earth, the sea, and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day. Wherefore
the Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hour it. Now there's Mark 2:27. And he
said unto them, the Sabbath was made for
man and not man for the Sabbath. So
think about it. Is this Sabbath day
according to the weekly cycle in order
of each day the same Sabbath here and
here? Is that what he's talking about?
Is it the same Sabbath? Just answer the
questions. Or is this Sabbath according
to the weekly cycle in order of each day
a different Sabbath? Is this Sabbath the
first day Sabbath or the seventh day
Sabbath? Now remember these guys, I'm
going to get into it here so you can see
what they say. You're going to see that
Miles believes that there was the first
day Sabbath in creation. So I'm just
asking the question, which one of these
is it? Is it the seventh day Sabbath or
the first day Sabbath? Is this Sabbath
according to the weekly cycle and order
of each day the same seventh day or a
different seventh day than the seventh
day in the first week of creation? Now,
you may not understand some of this now,
but you will by the time we get through
it.
Now, Jeff, you're either ignorant on
this, misunderstood, or you're
dishonest. I already explained this
earlier, so I'm not going to belabor the
point, but he entirely misunderstood
what my chart was conveying and my own
words explaining it, which is why he
hasn't even bothered to play a single
second of my own words.
Jeff, you really need to study the
differences between the commands
substance and its ceremonial form. Days
are not eternal.
You're treating the days as though they
have some sort of inherent eternality.
Folks, here's another visual for you
all, including you, Jeff. Hopefully, you
aren't confused by another visual aid
paired with me explaining it.
I've shown this before.
There are two creation accounts in
reference here.
Redemption was a creation act of God. It
wasn't creation xnahilo, the creation of
the physical matter.
One of the creation acts was he brought
about the matter from nothing as the
first cause. This creation then became
tainted due to sin.
The first Adam failed to do what God
commanded of him. He was supposed to
obey, be fruitful and multiply, subdue
the earth, and take dominion of it. And
he was blessed to be in holy communion
with God.
The second Adam did what the first Adam
failed to do.
Not only does he perfectly do what the
first Adam failed to do, but he also
recreates, restores, redeems the
creation that man broke. Then he rules
and reigns over it, subduing all of his
enemies as they're being made his
foottool, which is the true fulfillment
of the command to subdue the earth and
take dominion over it. He obeyed God
perfectly as a man which the first Adam
did not.
In the original creation act, God did a
mighty miraculous work. He accomplished
that work successfully. Then he entered
his rest on the seventh day. Meaning he
ceased from creation exnahilo. He's not
doing that anymore.
And he hasn't been doing that since he
entered this rest.
God in Christ parallels God in creation
in the work of redemption or recreation.
He also did a mighty miraculous work
accomplished that work in full but
entered his rest on the first day.
Thus the new memorial
is when God entered his rest in the new
creation.
I don't want to sidetrack, but part of
the issue is the SDA idea of redemption
being an afterthought, a plan B. Because
part of what I'd argue is that the
memorial in the original creation
typified the new creation because God
was not unawares of what Adam and Eve
would do.
And from eternity past, it was always
the will and desire of the son to freely
give of himself as the one who would
redeem and save a people whom the father
had given him before the foundation of
the world. But Jeff, that's what Hebrews
4 is talking about. The author is
explaining how just like God in creation
did what he did, so too God in Christ in
redemption parallels that work and then
entered his rest.
This is why you have to understand the
Sabbath being rooted in creation, rest,
and redemption, not just focus on the
creation aspect.
There's a lot more going on here than
just hyperfocusing in on the memorial
day, the old creation memorial day at
that, which is a part of the ceremonial
form of the command and then missing the
bigger picture.
So, we compare Genesis 2 with Exodus 20.
on the seventh day. The seventh day.
Now, so we mention, we see here that God
mentions the seventh day and the seventh
day. Notice Exodus 20:10, but the
seventh day. All right. So, let's ask,
is the seventh day in Exodus 20:10,
according to each day in its order of
the weekly cycle, the same seventh day
as Genesis 2:2?
Now, remember Genesis 2, it says that
the Lord did what? God blessed the
seventh day. And then, of course, we
find the seventh day and the ten
commandments, don't we? Exodus 20:1. So,
we find Genesis 2, the 7th day. We find
Exodus 20, the 7th day, the Sabbath day.
Now, is the seventh day the Sab the
Sabbath day? It is, isn't it? Is that
what Exodus 20 says? Is this Sabbath day
in Exodus 201, according to each day in
its order of the weekly cycle, the same
seventh day in Exodus 20:1? Yes, it is.
It is right there. It is. Now, this
Sabbath day on the seventh day is not
simply one day in seventh because you're
going to hear people say that, but
rather the seventh day in sequential
order based on the weekly cycle of the
seventh day in creation. Not one single
time in the entire Bible is the seventh
day a cardinal number seven. Not one
single time. The seventh is ordinal, not
cardinal. Ordinal means a consecutive
sequential order. Okay? Not one time.
And is this seventh day in Exodus 2011
the same seventh day in Genesis 2:3
according to each day in its order of
the weekly cycle. These Bible texts and
contexts does a devastating blow to
Miles's first day, Sunday Sabbath in
Genesis as man's first week. This idea
of man's week and a different week,
God's week, is a manmade idea. Now, what
I've done is I've actually brought this
out before I got to what he actually
says because now you're going to be able
to see what he says on this very thing.
So, if this is true, does it mean that
if the Sabbath is in creation for all
mankind,
does that include Adam? And if all
mankind includes Adam, then that
eliminates the idea that the Sabbath was
or is just for the Jews only. Correct?
Why then does our first day of the week
Sunday keepers use the terms the Jewish
Sabbath and Christian Sabbath to make
this artificial distinction between the
two when the Sabbath is for all mankind?
Jeff, it's only an alleged devastating
blow when you're arguing against
something that wasn't claimed.
I already explained earlier what I meant
by the chart and man's week and God's
week. Go watch the presentation, folks.
It's in the description box. I never
claimed what he said.
The chart is simply a visual to show how
Adam and Eve came into existence and
based on evening to evening, their first
day of existence would have been the
seventh day of the week.
I did not say that there were two
different weeks with Adam and Eve's
first day being Sunday and God's week is
his seventh day. Jeff entirely
misunderstood or is misrepresenting the
reason for me even bringing this up.
This was the start of a redemptive
historical explanation of the doctrine
of the Sabbath. And I was showing how
it's a lot bigger than the SDA church
makes it. They zoom in on small aspects
of the hole and then try and draw those
out to be universals.
So in true irony, Jeff, you're burning
all these straw men playing with fire
and it's only burning yourself.
What's sad is you think that people like
myself, Philip Kaiser, and a merid of
others haven't heard these objections
before, haven't thought about this
before, etc.
is exactly why I said what I did
regarding SDA's not knowing what they're
criticizing
and why I said earlier this is going to
age like milk because all this stuff is
predicated on your faulty
misrepresentations.
I didn't claim there's a first day
Sabbath in Sunday Sabbath in Genesis.
Again, I'm going to keep bringing this
up. You yourself are going to make a big
deal in part two saying he says that
Adventists read the word Saturday into
Genesis and you leave off the fact that
I said it doesn't say Sunday either.
John's Parker's book says the Sabbath
transferred talking about the new
creation which means we're not saying
what you claim we are saying.
You need to study the way others are
using words and terminology and
understand what they mean by those
words.
It's why on this platform I'm always
talking about the great controversy
worldview and explaining for my audience
how the SDA system is defining things,
not putting my own spin on what they're
claiming by reading into it definitions
they don't meet. Notice he only cites
Exodus 20. I brought this up in my
presentation. I've said multiple times
we're going to get to this. They always
cite Exodus 20 and don't look at the
conjunction or or look at it in
conjunction with Deuteronomy 5. So, let
me help Jeff out here.
Before even reading, I'm going to be
crystal clear about my point.
Adventists will hear this and say, "It
still says the seventh day." Yes, we're
aware.
The point of bringing this up is that
within the second giving of the law,
that's what Deuteronomy means.
Deuteros is second and and
is is law. The second giving of the law.
Exodus was the first giving. Deuteronomy
is the second.
In the second giving, we see that the
fourth commandment changes in its
ceremonial form. And I'll explain what I
mean by that. Notice the sidebyside of
the two. What's the difference?
Exodus 28-11.
Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. Six days you shall labor and do
all your work, but the seventh day is a
Sabbath to the Lord your God. On it you
shall not do any work, you or your son,
or your daughter, your male servant, or
your female servant, or your livestock,
or your sojourer, who is within your
gates. For in six days the Lord made
heaven and earth, the sea, and all that
is in them, and rested on the seventh
day. Therefore the Lord blessed the
Sabbath day, and made it holy.
And then Deuteronomy 5:12-15.
Observe the Sabbath day to keep it holy
as the Lord your God commanded you. Six
days you shall labor and do all your
work. But the seventh day is a Sabbath
to the Lord your God. On it you shall
not do any work. You or your son or your
daughter or your male servant or your
female servant or your ox or your donkey
or any of your livestock or the sojourer
who is within your gates that your male
servant and your female servant may rest
as well as you. You shall remember that
you were a slave in the land of Egypt,
and the Lord your God brought you out
from there with a mighty hand and an
outstretched arm. Therefore, the Lord
your God commanded you to keep the
Sabbath day. And thus, the reading of
God's holy word.
Is everything about those identically
the same? Every single aspect?
No, they're not. Part of the ceremonial
form of the command has changed.
what is to be remembered changes. Now,
this doesn't mean that they weren't to
still remember God as creator. That's
not what I'm saying. But we see an
addendum, if you will, which is added to
the ceremonial form that is uh that it
was to also memorialize redemption.
Creation, rest, redemption.
As redemptive history is unfolding, more
revelations happening.
It's rooted in creation, rest, and
redemption. This is why the author of
Hebrews in chapter 4 ties the Sabbath to
both creation and redemption. The
largest portion of New Testament
literature we have on the subject of the
Sabbath is Hebrews 4. And the entire
point is that after explaining in
Hebrews 3 that Jesus is a better Moses
and a better Joshua, Jesus is leading a
better Exodus out of a worse slavery
than Egypt, slavery to sin.
and he's leading us into a better
promised land. Not earthly Canaan, but
the city of God.
This was made possible by the Lord Jesus
Christ, who redeemed the creation that
fell in the beginning. That's why the
gospel is good news. It's the news about
the person and work of Jesus, who he is,
and what he did.
It's why Christians are right when they
say Jesus is their Sabbath rest. Yes,
this is true.
Some of us are simply willing to
recognize one step further that just
like of old, there's still a memorial
day that serves as a landmark for when
we remember and celebrate the gospel,
which is what church worship is. We're
celebrating the accomplishment of our
redemption in the gospel. And we have
biblical basis for why we do this on the
first day. It's not traditions of man.
It's the day Jesus entered his rest
after accomplishing this recreation work
and entered his rest.
And until we physically arrive there,
that memorial day will continue until we
arrive at that place where our bodies
are glorified and we no longer need
physical rest.
Rest for our soul is a true and present
reality. But our bodies still need rest
until they're resurrected and glorified.
But in the first giving of the law found
in Exodus,
the Sabbath roots in creation. Later on
in redemptive history, it's rooted in
redemption. And what that proves is the
ceremonial aspects of the command can
change.
That's my point. The day is a part of
the ceremonial form.
And later in redemptive history, that
changes. It becomes the day that God in
Christ entered his rest from the
recreation of the fallen creation which
was the act of redemption
creation rest and redemption folks
perfectly consistent with this.
That's what the Sabbath and redemptive
history pointed to. It's all pointing to
Jesus even the days. The reason I made
such a big point about Adam and Eve's
first day being God's seventh was
because of this. It's not arbitrary.
that's pointing to Jesus, the second
Adam.
It's a small detail in scripture that
points us to Jesus even in the smallest
of details.
So Jeff, don't try and tell us that the
day can't change. Don't try and act like
it's some eternal unalterable, you know,
he talks about these things like, well,
in Revelation it says the ark of the
covenant with the ten commandments in
heaven. I mean, we're not going to get
into interpretive methods of of of
apocalyptic literature, etc.
But stop acting like the days are some
sort of eternal unalterable thing
because then like you're prophetist you
try and prove too much. Just because
there isn't a verbatim text that says
the Sabbath was changed to Sunday, that
doesn't prove that the essence of that
claim isn't present in the Bible. 95% of
your guys' teachings aren't verbatim
stated in the Bible. investigative
judgment, health message, Ellen White
possessing the spirit of prophecy,
national Sunday law, and on and on and
on. Don't hold unjust weights and
measures. God in the Proverbs says he
hates that.
Hebrews 4 explains exactly what I said
despite it not being verbatim worded
that way. And I showed this in the
presentation that he's criticizing
as it pertains to the phrases Jewish
Sabbath and Christian Sabbath.
Like we saw from William Twice and
Philip Shaw,
they both use these two phrases. Jeff
pointed to Kaiser's book where he also
uses the phrase the Jewish Sabbath. And
the only reason Jeff thinks this is a
problem is because he doesn't understand
what's being said.
To reiterate from earlier since he's
bringing this up again, myself and those
that hold my position are not using the
term Jewish Sabbath to refer to the
Sabbath only being for the Jews.
It is a landmark term. We are using it
to refer to a certain period of time.
It's a delineation between old and new
creation.
Jewish Sabbath refers to the period from
the beginning of in Genesis to the
inauguration of the new creation.
The Christian Sabbath refers to the
period from the resurrection through to
the second coming when the consummation
state is ushered in and we enter into
the antityypical promised land, eternity
with God, physically entering into God's
rest where Jesus has already gone ahead
of us as the forerunner.
That's the true veil that he entered in
as a forerunner. Hebrews 6:19-20, the
presence of God.
We're not using it like modern
evangelicalism and dispensationalists
do, which both came later in history
than my position. They use it to say the
Sabbath is exclusive to the Jews. So, I
agree your question would be problematic
for that position, but not for mine.
Jeff, you were so confident earlier that
you knew this position
and you boked and scoffed at my claim
that most Adventists don't. Yet over and
over and over again in this
presentation, you vindicate my claim by
your own questions and your own claims.
If you understood the position, you
should already know the answer and why
this question isn't a problem and how
the terms Jewish and Christian Sabbath
are being used by Christian sabotarians.
So, now let's look at God's week. SDAs
believe that God's seventh day Sabbath
is in creation and is for all mankind
and precedes Moses and the Jews. Now,
let's get to Sam and Miles. Watch what
they say. So, I'm going to ask a
question here. So, tell us Sam and
Miles, is the Sabbath in creation for
all mankind? Simple question. It's
either yes or no.
Remember Jesus said in Matthew 12:37,
here's what Jesus says. For by thy words
thou shalt be justified, and by thy
words thou shalt be condemned. So be
careful what you say when you answer
these questions. Be very careful. Isaiah
chapter 1 verse 18 tells us, "Come now
and let us reason together." So in this
discussion or dialogue in regard to
answering these questions, there should
be no name calling. I'm not going to
call Miles a name and I'm not going to
call Sam a name. So there should be no
name calling. We're just dealing with
the questions I'm raising about the very
text and the things we're going to talk
about in regard to this first day Sunday
Sabbath. So Sam was asked a question
about the Sabbath. Do you keep the
Sabbath? Well, Sam says, "Yes, I do keep
the Sabbath." Sam is saying this. He
says, "Yes, I do keep the Sabbath as
defined, explained, interpreted in the
New Testament." Okay. Well, let's see if
that's true. Sam argues that he keeps
God's Sabbath of creation based on two
points. Now, before I get into this,
what Sam does is he'll say, "You don't
know what he believes, so you're
creating a straw man argument." No, I
know exactly what Sam believes, and I'm
going to go into it. In the seal next
videos, I'll be covering exactly what
Sam and Miles believe on these passages.
Jeff, no, you don't. You don't. You've
misrepresented my position on this more
than anyone I've ever engaged with on
this thus far. And that's saying a lot
because I've engaged with thousands
thousands of people.
And here you really evidence you don't
know what you're talking about because
Sam and I don't have identical positions
on this.
So how are you going to show what we
believe when we disagree on some of the
components that you're trying to call
into question?
This is why I said in my defense of the
first day Sabbath presentation that
Adventists often operate in a false
binary on the subject. You either
believe what they do or you
automatically fall into this other camp.
It's only those two options when no it
isn't.
Bringing up Sam Shimone is irrelevant to
the presentation that you're critiquing,
Jeff. You're now jumping to a discussion
that I had where he asked me to come on
to his program and sit down and listen
to an SDA YouTuber who made a video
about it. So, we engaged that
totally different focus than my defense
of the first day Sabbath.
Again, Sam and I don't agree on every
aspect of the Sabbath, and that's fine.
Believe it or not, I'm friends with lots
of people that disagree with me
theologically on all sorts of matters
because believe it or not, I think you
can actually learn things from people
that think differently than you do.
I already answered his question. Yes, it
is. The ceremonial form of it can change
though, and it does change, but the
substance has always been the same. The
promise of entering God's rest is to be
proclaimed to all of creation. In the
highways and byways compel people to
come in. When one enters into Christ by
faith, they receive rest for their soul
and the promises of the gospel. One of
which is the promise of entering the
city of God, the eternal rest of God,
where Jesus has gone ahead of us as he
has already entered as the forerunner.
And until that happens, we have a
memorial that we gather on to celebrate
this, which is the first day of the week
when Jesus accomplished that redemption
and entered his rest.
Sam doesn't agree with me on the
Memorial Day aspect, but he does on the
substance. And that's fine. Most
Christians that disagree on this still
functionally recognize such by
corporately gathering on that Memorial
Day to celebrate our redemption. So I
don't really care if they disagree.
People are at varying stages in their
theological studies. Folks, I didn't
always affirm what I do now on this.
This didn't come to almost a decade
after being a Christian.
But I kept studying the biblical texts
in this area with a more dedicated focus
and was persuaded.
But trying to inject other people into
the mix doesn't disprove the
presentation you're primarily focusing
on.
You're referring here to Sam uh to when
he was speaking for himself regarding a
claim that Bible Flockbox made about it.
That doesn't deal with me or my
presentation.
But it's interesting because his way
around it would be, well, you're
bringing up a straw man argument of
something he never said. Well, we're
going to go on what he does say. And Sam
argues that he keeps God's Sabbath of
creation based on two points. Number
one, there's no evening and morning, the
seventh day. He uses this. And number
two, he uses Hebrews chapter 4 in the
New Testament. On these two, he bases
his conclusion about the Sabbath, God's
Sabbath, in distinction from Israel's
Sabbath. So, I'm not creating some kind
of straw man here. I'm just simply going
to tell you what he says, what he
believes.
Jeff, in the exact discussion with Sam
you're referencing, I presented how Sam
and I have different understandings on
certain aspects of the Sabbath, namely
Hebrews 4. So, you're either ignorant or
dishonest.
Shoot, Sam and I went talked about this
in the presentation, our differences.
He sat and and quietly listened. We talk
offline.
He said, "Yeah, you actually pointed out
some good things. I hadn't thought about
before. Hey, thanks.
And yes, you are attacking straw men
because you're bringing up Sam and his
own claims to then try and disprove my
presentation from a totally different
context when Sam doesn't speak for me.
You ignorantly think that Sam and I have
identical views on every aspect of the
Sabbath. And we don't.
Your entire presentation thus far has
been beating up straw men because you
don't actually understand what you
criticize despite your insistence that
my claim that most Adventists don't
understand is unfounded.
All because you own John's Parker's
book. Give me a break.
Give me a break. This is the evidence.
You are totally out of your depths on
this and you show that you haven't even
tried studying to learn what other
people actually believe, even if you
disagree.
Same with Miles. So point one, Sam comes
from the point of no evening and
morning. Now Del Riff says something
interesting about this. Dell Rasliff
says the seventh day account does not
have the formula and there was evening
and there was morning. This is what Dell
Rasv says in his books. So if every day,
this is Sam's conclusion that from God's
Sabbath to the seventh day and the next
day and the next day after and the day
after that is all considered God's
Sabbath. That means every day not just
one day the seventh day but every day is
God's Sabbath. So if every day is the
Sabbath as sand interprets no evening
and morning and the seventh day is not
limited to the seventh day only that is
that God rested and blessed and
sanctified then all the days that follow
the seventh day to the new heaven and
earth that Sam says the Sabbath ends
then that is indefinite days of time
undefined by the days of creation week
in the weekly cycle. Now this gets
interesting. So if I was to put a
paradigm together from that very first
week of creation and there's the seventh
day, this is what Sam would be teaching
that the day after the seventh day and
the day after that and the day after
that, all this would be every day would
be the Sabbath. That's what Sam's
talking about when there's no evening
and morning in Genesis in regard to the
seventh day.
Yeah. Because God hasn't been creating
exilo since he ceased. That was Sam's
point.
But then he brings up Dale Ratzoff.
Jeff, Dale Ratzoff wasn't a sabotarian.
He and I don't have identical views on
this. I have all the books you're
referencing. Just like you said, you
have John's Parker's book and I've read
all of Dale's books and I love Dale. He
was a great man. He was a godly man.
You're actually going to slander him in
part two like we're going to hear. So, I
I'll leave some of that for there. But
if you think arguing Dale's view on the
Sabbath somehow refutes me, you only
further evidence you have no clue what
you're talking about, despite your
insistence to the contrary.
But now we have to correct what he said
here. We'll leave some of the other
stuff for part two. We have to correct
Jeff's misrepresentation of both Sam and
Dale. Jeff, you are a dishonest man and
you're incredibly ignorant and have zero
business lecturing uh lecturing on this.
Despite my differences with Dale, he was
a sincere and godly man who loved the
Lord. And I'm going to silence your
misrepresentation of him. Jeff claimed
that Dale Ratzoff said the Sabbath day,
not having evening and morning, means
that every day was the Sabbath. But what
Jeff isn't telling you is that they
don't mean the same thing by the term
Sabbath that Jeff does.
They're using it in its literal sense,
rest.
He ceased from the work of creation
exhilo. He hasn't been doing that ever
since. It's not that he's not doing any
work after that. It's specifically that
work that he ceased from,
which would mean that every day after
that, God is at rest from that specific
work.
Jeff, that's not what you're portraying
their view as here. Let's listen to Dale
Ratzoff now speak for himself and see if
it matches what Jeff claims about him.
Okay, we're going to start with the
Sabbath in Genesis, the seventh day.
Now, remember that creation was
completed on which day?
That there is no creation week.
So, if you hear of creation week, you
say, "Oh, that's not right." Creation
was completed on the sixth day.
And God did not keep the Sabbath on the
seventh day. The Hebrew word there means
ceased. He ceased what? He ceased
creating the other things. Okay? And the
seventh day in Genesis is a very unique
day for a number of reasons. First,
there is no formula. And there was
evening and there was morning, a seventh
day. And I believe that the conditions
present on that first seventh day would
have continued forever. Now I'm not
saying there wouldn't be an eighth day,
ninth day and so on if man had not
sinned. And that was the one day
uh when in scripture when man and God
were in right relationship with each
other.
Now, is that how Jeff portrayed what
Dale Ratzoff was saying regarding the
seventh day not having evening and
morning or not?
No, it isn't.
Dale's point was that God ceased from
creation and did not resume such
activity on the eighth day, 9inth day,
etc. Sam was saying the exact same thing
and explain such in the video that
you're trying to cherrypick from. And
your chart only further proved the
point, Jeff. God didn't pick back up
creating Xnahilo. He's been done with
that since he created or or since he
entered his rest from the original
creation act.
And in my presentation you referenced at
the beginning of your video responding
to Mark Finley, I walk through John 5
where Jesus himself reiterates this. In
fact, Sam did as well in the video you
referenced with him.
Jesus chastises the Jews for trying to
condemn them uh him and the disciples
because he says that both he and his f
excuse me because he says that he and
his father had been working on the
Sabbath.
He doesn't mean that they were creating
exilo creation out of nothing but they
were upholding the creation redeeming
that creation etc. That's a work.
Jeff made a big deal multiple times in
this presentation that Christians will
use the terms God's Sabbath in
distinction to Israel Sabbath. Yes,
Jeff, because the psalter and the author
of Hebrews do. It's biblical.
Notice Hebrews 4 1-10
to close things out here. We're going to
walk through this yet again.
Therefore, this is after the author has
explained Moses and Joshua were a type
that pointed to Jesus, who's a better
mediator and a better Joshua, leading a
better Exodus out of a far worse bondage
to slavery than Egypt, the bondage to
sin.
So therefore, while the promise of
entering his rest, that's God's rest,
still stands,
let us fear, lest any of you should seem
to have failed to reach it. For good
news, that's gospel, came to us just as
to them, Israel. But the message they
heard, the gospel, did not benefit them
because they weren't united by faith
with those who listened.
Ah, so you enter into this rest by
faith, by believing.
For we who have believed enter that
rest, as he has said, now he quotes the
psalter.
As I swore in my wrath, they shall not
enter my rest, God's rest. Although his
works were finished from the foundation
of the world, ah the creation work
exnahilo.
For he has somewhere spoken of the
seventh day in this way. And God rested
on the seventh day from all his works.
And again in this passage he said they
shall not enter my rest God's rest
since therefore it remains for some to
enter it God's rest and those who
formally received the good news failed
to enter because of disbelief or
disobedience Israel again he appoints a
certain day today saying through David
so long afterward in the words already
quoted today if you hear his voice do
not harden your hearts.
This is talking about the belief. You
can believe today, right now, any day,
and have rest for your soul.
For if Joshua had given them rest, God
would not have spoken of another day
later on.
So then,
there remains a sabatismos,
a Sabbath rest for the people of God.
For whoever has entered God's rest has
also rested from his works as God did
from his. Thus the reading of God's holy
word. So I gave my ex Jesus of this
paricopy in the presentation that Jeff
is critiquing. We also have an article
on our website where I break it down as
well. And we heard no engagement with
this thus far, just assertions that I
got this from other people. Well, that
doesn't prove that my understanding
isn't consistent with the biblical text.
And the uh at this point in the message,
like I said, the author is explaining
the type before then explaining the
antitype.
Just like there was a rest proposed to
the Israelites to enter into, there's
also a rest that's extended to us, New
Testament Christians, for us to enter
into. They had Canaan preached to them
as the promised land. We have the
eternal city of God. This is not to say
that the promise of eternity with God
wasn't for them also. But their story is
a picture for the modern Christian and
that's how the author is using them.
Remember the lesser to the greater
this Sabbath rest that remains for us to
enter into. That's God's rest. God's
Sabbath.
That's the author of Hebrews, Jeff. Not
Sam Shimone, not Philip Kaiser, not
Johns Parker, not John Owen, not
answering Adventism, the biblical
writer. And he's using the psalter to
explain for us what's going on here.
Notice another thing that Owen actually
points out regarding verse six
specifically.
Another non-presbyterian scholar before
John's Parker's day, by the way.
So regarding verse six which says since
therefore it remains for some to enter
it and those who formerly received the
good news failed to enter because of
disobedience. Owen writes this therefore
is the substant uh the substance of this
verse besides the rest of God from the
foundation of the world and the
institution of the seventh day Sabbath
as a pledge thereof. There was another
rest for men to enter into, namely the
rest of God, and his worship in the land
of Canaan. This being proposed unto the
people of old, they entered not into it
by reason of their unbelief.
Close quote.
So, catch that.
Beside the rest of God in creation at
the foundation of the world, which the
seventh day Sabbath was a pledge of,
there's another rest for men to enter
into, the rest of God. This is why verse
four brings up the creation account in
Genesis.
Owen points out that there being a a
rest of God would mean that a type of
work would have would have to precede
it.
If you rest from something, that means
you had been doing something to rest
from, basically. And this is when the
author of Hebrews is still talking about
Israel, the type and shadow before
transitioning to how Jesus is better.
And Owen rightly notices how in the text
there are two types of work in focus.
Both the act of God and creation at the
beginning, as well as the mighty act of
God delivering Israel out of Egypt. Two
things the Sabbath are rooted in,
creation and redemption. He continues,
quote, "This thing done, God rests or
enters into his own rest." Then he cites
the psalter here. He in the ark of his
strength arose and entered into his rest
in answer to his rest after his
finishing of the works of the first
creation. Psalm 132:8. The settlement of
his worship and the typical
representation of his presence among the
people therein, shadowing out his
glorious presence in him in whom the
fullness of the godhead was to dwell
bodily. He calls it his rest and his own
rest. And here on ensued a double rest
proposed to the people. Ah,
this is why the Greek grammar,
regardless of what the SDA church says,
oh, you don't need any of that. Yes, you
do. Yes, you do. The Bible was not
written in English. It is helpful to
refer to people who understand the Greek
language and can help point out these
things that can oftenimes be lost in
translation. Praise God that we have
translations in our own vernacular.
But there is a double rest that is
proposed here. The Greek language shows
this one, a spiritual rest in God as
having entered into a special covenant
with them. Upon God's rest on the
creation, men were invited to enter into
God's rest as the God of nature upon the
terms and according unto the law of
creation. But by sin, this rest was
rendered useless and unprofitable unto
all mankind. And the covenant itself
lost all its power of bringing men unto
God. This is what I was saying, Jeff,
about the rest of man became tainted in
the fall.
But now in this erection of a new church
state among the posterity of Abraham,
the foundation of it was the premise
made unto Abraham, which contained in it
the substance of another covenant, where
unto God through Jesus Christ would
enter and rest therein, whereon he
invites them by faith and obedience to
enter into it also into the rest of God.
And then two, there was a pledge of this
spiritual rest proposed unto the people,
and this was the land of Canaan, and the
quiet proposition thereof, and exercised
of the worship of God therein. By this,
and their respect unto it, God tried
their faith and obedience as to that
spiritual rest, which, as it were, lay
hid under it.
And herein it was that they failed whose
example is proposed and considered in
this chapter.
Close quote.
The author of Hebrews is using Israel as
an example for us and he's making a
compare and contrast for his original
Jewish convert here. He points out these
realities that the Jewish believer would
have been acutely aware of like Moses
and Joshua and the Exodus and the
Sabbath, etc. And he's explaining how
Jesus is what all of that pointed to.
But within all of those things, there
are parallels that Jesus himself did.
Israel in the wilderness had the gospel
preached to them, but they failed to
enter Canaan due to their unbelief. So
too, there's a rest being offered to us,
the New Testament Christian, to believe
the gospel and also enter into Christ by
faith and receive spiritual rest.
The phrase God's rest essentially refers
to the gospel, the person and work of
Jesus, and the call to believe the
gospel and enter in. Don't harden your
hearts like Israel did. The wilderness
is like a picture of life.
And Jesus is leading his people through
this wilderness to the promised land,
the eternal consummation state.
And as I showed in the presentation that
Jeff is critiquing, verses 8 to 10
become pivotal.
For if Joshua had given them rest, God
would not have spoken of another day
later on. So then there remains a
sabatism, a Sabbath rest for the people
of God. For whoever has entered God's
rest has also rested from his works as
God did from his.
Two pivotal aspects are the phrase
sabatismos,
which is uniquely used here. The author
actually made this word up and it's
translated as Sabbath rest in verse 9.
Or it could be Sabbathkeeping or Sabbath
day.
This is different from elsewhere in this
chapter where the term rest or God's
rest is translated as cataposis
and this matters badly or big time.
Sabatismos refers to daykeeping,
weekly daykeeping. Cataposus refers
antypically to God's rest, the eternal
state.
Which is why Owen points out, and I
agree with him, the text is saying that
there's a day that remains to
memorialize this rest of God that we can
enter into just like there was a day
that memorialized God entering his rest
in the original creation, that day in
the new creation being the first day.
But that leads to the second pivotal
component, the phrase for whoever in
verse 10, as the uh ESV renders it.
Owen and other Greek grimarians point
out that this for whoever
is singularly personal in the Greek,
meaning it's referring to one
individual, not a corporate group of
individuals.
So some translators will say that what's
being said is that when a believer
believes the gospel, they cease from
their works and then enter into God's
rest like God rested from his. And
that's what verses 9 and 10 are saying.
Now, it's true that the author did say
back in verse three that when we
believe, we enter. But something of
bigger magnitude is being said in verses
9 and 10.
The author says the one who entered into
God's rest did so in like manner to God
back in creation.
That's pivotal.
He's making a parallel. God in creation
and the Exodus did a mighty miraculous
work, accomplished that work, and then
entered his rest. That's not what the
believer does when they ceased from
their works and trust in Christ.
God rested and then looked over his work
with joy.
The believer doesn't rest from their
sinful works and then look back over
those works with joy. It's not a good
parallel. It doesn't fit. However,
Jesus, the single person, does fit both
grammatically and contextually
because he did do a parallel work that
was mighty and miraculous.
He redeemed or recreated the sinstained
creation. He accomplished that mighty
work in full. And then he entered his
rest after accomplishing that work,
looking back over that accomplished work
with glee and joy.
But he entered the first day when the
work was finished, not the seventh.
That's why a Sabatism moss, a Sabbath
day does still remain for the people of
God that memorializes this work, the day
that God in Christ entered his rest in
the new creation, the first day when he
walked out of the tomb.
Now, we will pick back up where we left
off in part two. But so far, all Jeff
has proven is that my claims still hold
water.
And to answer the question of the night,
no, Jeff Dowel didn't refute my
position. He hasn't even entered the
arena of reasoning together like Isaiah,
who he referred to, says. You need to do
better homework, Jeff. I'm not just
saying that. You have no clue what
you're talking about.
The whole thesis of my presentation that
he referred to was to explain for people
regardless of if they agree or disagree
what my position is, how it's arrived
at, and then show how Adventist
criticisms miss the mark.
And I use Doug Bachelor as a case sample
and his claims were not unique to him.
They're standard par for the course SDA
objections. And Mr. Dowel only
reinforced this fact in what we heard
this evening. I have yet to encounter
the Adventist that can steal man the
position even if they disagree. Once
that happens, I will shake that
Adventist hand, look him dead in the
eyes and say, "You have my respect. Good
on you." But Jeff, you have not earned
that respect.
I sat under Adventist teaching for two
decades, believed the teachings, learned
the teachings, procilitized the
teachings, understood the teachings up
through the university level.
Don't tell me that I'm just paritting
other people. Now, I studied this topic
very broadly, sir. And I didn't always
hold to this position.
It's very clear he doesn't respect my
biblical studies, and he thinks I'm just
regurgitating others. And in one sense,
yes, I am because I stand on the
shoulders of giants. I'm not some rogue
theological agent.
But this idea did not originate with
John's Parker or Philip Kaiser, and I
didn't get it from them.
I read widely on this subject, hearing
varying ideas and views and tested them
against scripture to see who's whose
works best, whose is most consistent.
And this also involved studying various
hermeneutical methodologies and seeing
which one is the most consistent in its
application.
And I am convinced of the Christian
Sabbath view. Not because that's what I
personally prefer. That's not how it
works. I want to know what the actual
what the author intended to communicate.
Not what I want to be there. Not what I
think supports my own personal, you
know, whatever, but because I believe
it's the most faithful to not just solar
scriptor, but tota scriptor, all of
scripture, not just cherrypicked proof
texts, and then just having a proof text
war back and forth with an adventist.
When looked at holistically and in full,
this position can make sense of the
Sabbath in full,
not cherrypicked portions of redemptive
history.
And that goes for both the Adventist
view and the non-sabotarian view. I know
a lot of people, the vast majority of
people in my audience disagree with me.
That's fine. I'm just stating where I'm
coming from, sharing the information.
Study it out for yourself.
But Jeff, you shouldn't be throwing
stones in a glass house, buddy, because
you're an Ellen White parrot. You have
an extra biblical worldview that the
leadership of your organization tells us
doesn't come from scripture itself, but
was uniquely given to you all by way of
your prophetus. You then bring this
worldview to the Bible to do the
interpreting. So, I look forward to
hearing your responses to my challenges.
I don't know if you'll spend the time,
you know, responding to literally every
or I don't know if I'll spend the time,
video he makes because it sounds like
he's going to be doing four or five
parts. Mercy, we made it through not
even like a quarter of this first one.
But if he continues this poorly in the
rest of them, I'm not sure it's going to
be worthwhile.
However, Jeff, I look forward to you
addressing the issues I've raised
tonight. Things I've been waiting for an
Adventist to answer for me for I don't
even know how long.
And thank you all for being uh for being
here. And may Christ richly bless you in
the grace and peace won by Jesus Christ
and his vicarious death on the cross for
sinners. Hallelujah. Marinatha. Until
next time.
[Music]